e
e e
oh
but this little tool holds the cell
phone all right we're starting a little
late it's uh 4 minutes past 10 we were
supposed to start at 10: um but I'm
going to go ahead and convene uh finance
division 3 today is a division work
session uh not expecting any votes uh
we're going to be hearing uh pretty much
all day uh from the office of the
commissioner of the
DHHS um we've received a nice binder of
budget
presentations and we have an equally
nice
hb1 that we can consult and um and so uh
we'll get going and I'll just I'll just
ask you to be patient with us as we go
back and forth we I I love the
presentation but we have to be able to
see uh which line items we're referring
to all right uh so with that uh I should
have clicked it already but let's
go good morning members of the committee
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer um
I would also ask for patience this being
the first day and I think we're all just
going to kind of get used to what we're
looking at here and so what's before you
um as uh the chair indicated there is a
binder there we will be bringing the
subsequent presentations and and we kind
of set that up with tabs so you can add
to that as we move forward through this
process so if you can start by you open
up your binder and the first
presentation there should be the
division of finance um so I thought it
was appropriate to kick off the budget
detail conver detail conversations with
talking about the division of finance
that supports um the entire department
and in the back towards the back of your
book and I don't know if you want to
take it out of the binder for today we
also have the budget briefing book
sections for the office of the
commissioner um the division of finance
is in accounting unit
5676 which in the budget briefing book
is page five and in the governor's
budget it is Page
1, and 40 uh again the budget briefing
book it's page five and then the
governor's budget is page
1,40 where it starts okay just let us
catch up of course and and say the 1,000
number again 1 what
1,40 40
yes um so while I'm thumbing through
this uh for those who are interested uh
we're going to we're going to take a
serious 2hour run at this and then we're
going to take a a recess for lunch and
then come back probably around 1:00
depending on exactly when we uh
recess um go ahead excellent so if you
um if you open up the the presentation
the for the division of finance there uh
the second page in there is the the
mission for the division of finance um
division of finance does does a couple
of really key things um we provide
reliable financial data data management
and then also within our division we
also uh ad Minister all of the
solicitations the rfps rfas contracts
amendments so forth and so on and we try
to do this in a comprehensive and
collaborative manner across the
department we work with every single
division um both on the financial side
and on the procurement side of of the
hat so on any given day I may talk to
every single um division director or
their counterparts um either through the
contracts work or the finance work that
our team supports so so I just want to
make sure I'm tracking with you I I I I
think uh in this thick staple yes we're
on page five looking at the office of
business operations that is correct and
you're you're also referring to it as
finance that is correct the division of
finance okay yeah yeah so what what you
will see I I think you actually make a
really good point representative Edwards
what you will see as we move uh through
the budget is sometimes the operating
name name May differ from the accounting
unit name and there's some history
behind that we do work on an ongoing
basis to update those we have a small
period in February of every other year
to get the chart of accounts updated but
there will be some discrepancies but but
I will point that out going forward I
apologize for the oversight no no no
problem
um the the good thing about not knowing
exactly what I'm doing is I can
anticipate the questions of the Freshman
so um okay and then just to again to
make sure that we're tracking on on page
1041 um there's a a bottom
line I think or is it a top line that
says estimated source of funds for
office of business operations is okay so
that's the beginning of of what we're
we're looking at um that that's the end
so on page
1040 uh you you'll see the accounting
unit detail where you have the 5 95 95
9500 and then 5676 that's the accounting
unit um and then it begins at that class
10 the Personnel line there in front of
you and then it continues onto the onto
the second page give me give me a second
do you do you see that
Moran is okay so is this it
yeah which were right
here okay and I'm I'm sorry for being
slow on this but uh once once we get
this going it'll it'll go of course all
right thank you all right so um just to
start pretty high level on page three of
the PowerPoint presentation that we
provided I have a highle oversight of
the types of functions um that are
support of the specific functions that
are supported the bulk of our staff um
are really related to what what I kind
of think about as being expenditures
this is the daily financial management
um we have Finance directors that
oversee their respective areas so we
have a finance director assigned the
division of long-term support support
supports and
services um and also the division for
Behavioral Health we have one division
director for the Medicaid Program we
have one division director for the
division of Public Health Services and
we've tried to allocate those
appropriately based on on the workloads
that we see and this this is incredible
team of folks that do the audit
activities the the daily AP AR the
financial oversight they're looking at
expense projections they're transf
they're they're preparing those
transfers that the fiscal committee sees
to make sure that we have the money in
the right place and it's budgeted and
tracked appropriately and what's also
really important here too is looking at
the source of funds the requirements
that may be attached to those making
sure that we spend those maintenance of
effort dollars that are required and and
that's the bulk of the work that the
team does on a daily basis we also have
a revenue and Reporting team and this is
the team that that does the the federal
draws does a lot of the uh federal
reporting we do expenditure reports for
over 200 different
programs um they they they work on the
the the draw Downs the CMS 64 report is
a quarterly report that our team does
it's in the hundreds of Millions of
dollars every quarter um that that team
reviews and that that takes a tremendous
amount of preparation and then also
responsible here is the team that looks
over the public assistance cost
allocation plan so that's that plan that
I had mentioned yesterday is 250 260
pages long that allows us to allocate
Federal costs um as approved by the
federal government to all of our
programs
appropriately we also relatively knew uh
about four year a little less than four
years ago we established a rate setting
team before rate setting was kind of
done in a decentralized manner we
centralize that so the med the um $34
million of Medicaid rates that were
appropriated uh via hb2 from chapter 79
laws of 2023 this is the team that did
all the tremendous amount of work in
analyzing the hundreds and if not
thousands of different individual rates
comparing the Medicare rates Medicaid
rates they also work on looking at they
they rebase the County Nursing Facility
rates twice a year they do that work on
an ongoing basis they look at the cost
reports and um it's it's a relatively
small team but but they do quite a
tremendous amount of work there the
Contracting team the Contracting bureau
there's 34 FTE there this team on any
given year typically about 7 to 800
contracts and amendments go through this
team now an amendment could take
anywhere from a month to 3 months
depending on complexity a contract could
take 6 months or a year a lot of that is
often dependent upon whether there's it
components whether there's unique or
risk components that we need to take
into account um or uh often times we do
have trouble with some of our vendors
where they may want to go back and forth
on a document I've seen that happen for
eight months at a time where we're not
able to get to agreement on certain
terms that's certainly the Rarity but
it's part of the normal course of
business for Better or For Worse and
sometimes it's something we can't
control they also um administer all of
the rfps and rfas there's state law that
specifies very particular rules around
what can be shared with our vendors when
it can be shared and and the processes
that we must follow there and that
team's responsible they they put out
about 55 or 60 of those solicitations
each year and then finally there's also
a grants U management team and and this
came into being seven or eight years ago
following some changes at the federal
reel level around subrecipient
monitoring we talked a lot about
subrecipients and contractors last bium
uh this is the team that oversees the um
and helps administer the system where we
assess the risk of all of our
contractors before we enter into
agreement we look at their financials we
look at their programmatic risk have
they had changes in oversight leadership
uh do they have do they have history
administering this contract and then
based on those risks the contract team
incorporates elements into the contract
to account for the risks that have been
identified so those two um those two
components there work very closely
together I have a a couple generic
questions that sound will sound familiar
by the time we get through all of this
um what what is your your vacancy right
here and are there any of these uh stove
pipe functions these five functions that
have trans transferred uh into the
division of finance and procurement
since like
2019 the since
2019 yeah going back aways we're just
sort of preco the these so the
Contracting
team was previously under another
component but I think that was pre 20109
it was under another area of the
department but I believe that's organiz
the department has changed right um
there were 18 positions that were
unfunded in this area so basically all
of the vacant positions that were uh
vacant at that point in time were
unfunded in the governor's budget so
what is that put us that uh quick back
to the envelope here so that's
010 personal services that's that going
from 10.8 to
9.9 in 26
going from 25 10.8
to 26 starting at 9.9 yep yep so it's in
in class 10 you you will see the the
reduction there for the 18 vacant
positions
okay or vacant and and now unfunded
positions okay so what what kind of
turnover do you experience here and and
if you do have turnover uh how difficult
it is it and General to train somebody
up to be productive sure so the state
state accounting the state system itself
is fairly unique so um at at my finance
director level um in in my time in this
role three plus years now um I've had
one individual turnover there and that
was due to retirement she decided to
retire um at the Financial Manager level
we have Rel I mean overall a relatively
low uh turnover rate at the lower levels
particularly at the AP level where where
it's a the salary and compensation is
not um as generous we tend to see higher
turnover there but um we but overall
relatively low it's about 11% vacancy
rate um which is below the department
average all right thank you of course
represent no Alco yeah just quickly I
missed the total actual headcount number
um well um I think that's what you were
asking is there if if you look at the
governor's Budget on page
1,41 you you you will see the total
actual headcount uh right there at 157
for the Governor's budget at the bottom
of the page thank you of
course okay thank you yep so turning the
page to just some of the key
accomplishments that we've seen um one
really important piece that the team has
been working on one really important
initiative is um we had procured a
business uh budget business intelligence
tool back in
2022 and the purpose of that is that
historically we found that we did not
have the data analysis available to
actively and quickly identify where the
federal funds were being earned and so
what what that led to was led to a
number of years um and representative
walner you probably remember this you
know 5 six seven eight years ago where
we had large amounts of federal revenue
laps and the purpose of the system is to
allow us to budget more actively and be
able to track what the maintenance of
expenditures is in real time and so if
you look at the bullets there so the
state fiscal year 24 general fund lapse
was about 70% Less in in 4 than in 23
and the federal and other Revenue lapse
was 88% less so I I think this the last
bolt there is a really important one
where the year prior we lapsed $45
million of federal funds that we could
have used to offset General funds had we
budgeted more accurately but um and and
then in 24 where we budgeted more
accurately and we used the system we
only lapsed $5 million of federal dollar
of federal funds and so that that system
is it does you know there is a price to
to it it's a couple hundred, a year but
the savings that's generated to offset
general fund expenditures is really
critical um Ernie uh J Jillian will be
talking about this later on this was a
prioritized need to keep that funded
it's currently not funded in our budget
that certainly gives me some concern and
it's something that I'd want to
highlight here the contracts team has
been undergoing I I talked about this
previously they've been undergoing U we
we adopted a lean Six Sigma business
methodology within within that team and
we it it specifically it's a domic
methodology where we Define the system
we measure the system we constantly
assess through vendor surveys and
internal surveys then we improve and
then we control for that and so we've
continued to see pretty good pretty
positive outcomes but what we've tried
to do lately is work with um the
nonprofits in the community to provide
training because you probably if you've
talked to anyone that's done business
with the state the procurement process
and the GNC process it's a little
foreign and so what we've tried to do
there is provide training to our
external vendors and nonprofits in the
community to try to kind of lift the
veil on what what you know what what are
the constraints what are the problems
we've tried to address those as well as
some of the federal um help interpret
some of the federal rules relative to
indirect cost indirect cost is something
that a contractor can claim to offset
you know their general overhead and not
everybody has done that consistently and
we've heard um feedback from the
community that that's a challenge for
some so we've tried to address that
through re through a couple of projects
via reaching out um we've also through
just the resources that we've had put
together a finance Academy where we've
tried to document um and standardize the
policies and procedures that the team
follows we we utilize the the state uh
accounting system but there's always
intricacies with any culture um that
need to be documented so that when you
do hire do on board it's a little bit
more consistent as far as what folks are
coming into and they also have recorded
trainings that they can they can go back
to to try to make things a little bit
more effective efficient and lead to
fewer uh mistakes whoopsies and
otherwise so so you picked my interest
because you've talked about it systems
twice with this business intelligence
tool and then uh in contracts you're
migrating to a webbased application um
are you are you able to tell us uh the
names of the key it systems that you're
using just so yes if we're talking about
it in the future we're we're hearing
each other yeah the the um budget
business intelligence tool that is
Salesforce and the um the Excel based uh
data basically we brought cell to its
Brink and broke it and we built our own
um project management system and then we
had to bring it back a little bit and we
migrated that to uh smart sheets um
contracts also relies during the
pandemic we um quickly rolled out the
docy sign e signature prior to that
people used to drive around the state
getting wet signatures um when I first
started I was previously the contracts
director kind of drove me crazy took us
two weeks to get execution the record
now I think is 27 minutes to get the
vendor to sign DHHS to sign and the
Attorney General's office to sign and is
a docky sign function and smart sheet or
where uh no it's it's it's separate
completely different system um that is
also currently a PN that was not funded
and I would uh you know certainly be
concerned uh if that didn't go forward
because it would negatively impact um
both our vendors and we have to find
some kind of workaround solution is it
in the governor's budget it is not
currently funded in the governor's
budget okay so so highlight that for us
because that sounds like one of the
first really major productivity tools
that I've heard in the it
area yes that has um definitely
accelerated the
processes okay another question
represent so what does LMS stand for in
the LMS platform is that life cycle
management learning I I believe it
believe it's learning management system
learning management system yes um and uh
maybe you'll get to this but maybe this
is part of the business uh intelligence
tool but you know the budget in this
department has uh the general fund cost
going down by 4 million and the amount
of federal funds going up by 2 million
so the percentage uh applicable of of
you know this office function is really
dramatically changed and um um can you
explain that and you know tell us how
you did it and um there there's probably
a there's probably a couple of things
impacting that number one is just
budgeting as accurately as possible
using leveraging that tool the second
component there is when the um when
looking at unfund the 394 positions
General funds was a factor in that
process and 18 positions have been
unfunded within this accounting
unit so uh followup and so um you you
know basically you have 4 million of
general fund savings within just this
function and um and are you would you
say that um you know part of the
prioritized needs would be to keep the
information systems available that made
this possible yes and and um Ernie was
going to address that later on in his
presentation when he presents uh the
Bureau of Information Services so we
should dig back into those thank you so
so do you I'm sorry representative PRI
go
ahead thank you uh Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question as a followup
to a question that uh representative uh
Ed Edwards asked you what is that name
of the program for the doc sign that is
not in the governor's budget and that we
should be aware of and the amount of
money that is needed sure it it docus
sign is is the program and we've uh
rolled that out to a couple other areas
in the department as well and I I I know
that uh when when Ernie and Dave speak
they can give you a little bit more
detail and in that presentation we have
the specific numbers that are
highlighted in there so those will be
coming today thank you okay so it sounds
like you're you don't want to uh that
you got it delegated to have the it
discuss separate from your department
which bugs me but but I get it um uh so
so Mr weeders when we get to talking
about Salesforce I'll be interested in
knowing what's next you know given that
we have Salesforce given that it's such
a powerful tool what are your next
adventures in increasing productivity as
a result of using
Salesforce all right and did you have a
question yes a quick question on the
lapse I know that uh in the past lapses
have been been built into the budget
with expected that that uh amount was
going to lapse is that is that still a
continuing process so when the yes when
the LBA prepares um it it's its final
analysis it shows the lapse as a
percentage which typically ranges 3.6 4%
in recent years okay thank you of course
we're we're okay uh we can keep asking
questions but we do have a fairly busy
so so what please ask I understand that
thank you Mr chairman on uh 022 rents
leases other than
State could you explain the uh
relatively increase
of the request that you're making and
and give me an explanation for that sure
so um the department the Department
administrative Services they administer
all of the Statewide contracts um they
repr procured a Statewide contract for
copiers and we tack onto that contract
uh per RSA 21 by and um we've seen an
increase in The copier leasing cost
which is reflected
there okay thank you that was an
excellent question exactly the kind
we're supposed to be asking today thank
you thank you your your mic is on did
you have another
question okay all right um so give
people just a moment I think you're
about done on this section could just
give give uh the members a moment to to
look through this to see if they have
any uh supplemental questions before we
move on please
representative nvan yeah I have a quick
question and and sorry in looking at
uh uh 103 line 103 so there's nothing in
fiscal year 24 nothing in fiscal year 25
but then money in uh 26 and 27 and I was
noticing patterns throughout when I kind
of thumb through this and I'm I'll
apologize that I'm new at understanding
um how uh how this budget uh detail
works but I noticed a couple of places
and there's an example of it where there
was nothing in 23 24 and suddenly
there's money in 24 and
25 so maybe help me understand what's
going on there sure so um I I'll I'll
just highlight a couple of areas uh just
to talk about the zeros so the
additional fringe benefits in class 42
you see it goes from 379 and the
adjusted authorized in state fiscal year
25 to Zer we centralized that so that's
actually an accounting unit 5,000 now
and then to your question on class 103
going from 0 to 448 that represents the
contract that we have uh with a provider
for EBT cards and that that was
previously budgeted elsewhere and we've
moved that uh under under this
accounting unit and that's why you see
that
increase so a quick follow yeah go ahead
so wherever wherever I see that kind of
a pattern that reflects moving uh moving
money from one one area to another or
relabeling it may or it may not and I
think that's one of the challenges and
that's where like we need to have
conversations because in some cases
there could be a reduction in other
cases there could be uh a contract has
ended that we didn't repr procure in
some cases it could be that we're moving
money over um or it may be something it
could it could actually reflect a
prioritized need that was funded in
other cases so I think if you ever see
something like that best to
ask okay thank
you so um I I just heard you say we
moved EBT in in into this group and and
I think for cost transparency that
doesn't pass the common sense test but
there must be a reason why you did that
I would think EBD costs would be best
associated with the kind of the food
program area so that we can see total
costs so the the individ ual that
oversees the EBT program the contract
itself that administers more of the
technical Administration actually sits
within finance and so this was
previously budgeted in accounting unit
6125 which is the Bureau of family
assistance and the director's office and
so we move that because the individual
who is managing the dollars actually
works within Finance they they obviously
have close ties to the program but this
is more of the general oversight of the
cards and the administration
and working with um with the federal
government on more of the technical
issues okay but if we didn't have an e
EBT program uh well okay I'll just leave
you with that I it doesn't it doesn't
make any sense to me because for the
purposes of cost transparency it should
to me be allocated in the functional
area so we can see the total cost of a
of a program or a service but I I'm I'm
not I'm not going to debate it I'm just
going to let you know sure um all right
any other questions on on the budget
detail on pages 1,40 or
1041 nope okay um the only other and I'm
just being mindful of the time um I did
include a couple of slides if you flip
to page seven
um you will see this is just some of the
data that we've been tracking over time
relative to the uh the efficiencies of
the contracts team um and and you will
slowly see that we are producing uh more
contracts in a faster amount of time
earlier than the in the year than we
have in Prior years what we've also
discovered as we've sort of formalized
um the the system and tighten things up
a little bit of you know we have
identified other contracted needs that
previously went unmet so that will also
give give rise to that number there but
overall um that's all I have for the
division of finance and um um take any
other questions on that otherwise we can
move forward to EAP just just to
compliment on on slide six I I know I
know that since you've moved in there's
been a tremendous amount of
reorganization and Improvement in this
office so so thank you for
that right so if we want to move the
next um presentation is on the employee
assistance
program and I am joined here do you want
to introduce
yourself
thank I'm Mike Lawless good morning I'm
the director of the employee assistance
program okay get us get us oriented I I
see a a slide deck what what page of the
briefing book are we in and where are we
in the budget yes so if you turn to the
budget book page 140 um we should should
be close to there you will see
accounting unit
5025 yeah true so I see where it it's
got estimated source of funds for the
EAP and then it goes down to right
above Health and Social
Services yes and I apologize starts on
1039 yeah thank you it starts on one on
uh 1039
yep and in the budget briefing
book if you flip the budget briefing
book to page uh two I believe yes on it
begins on page two of the budget
briefing
book all right thank
you so I appreciate your time and and
the opportunity to speak a little bit
about the employee assistance program
I brought some additional resources here
I don't know if I can maybe pass them
around if folks are curious but these I
don't know that they're
necessary presentation I could I could
speak to them a little bit and part of
this is also within the presentation
yeah um the material is around resources
that we provide to individuals and also
uh specific um resources for managers
and so the EAP it began as a pilot
program serving 900 state employees in
1985 and has grown through the years to
support all departments and uh also
state employees family
members some of the information uh
around the program are around the
confidentiality of the program different
uh resources that we connect with folks
connect folks to either internally or
externally and some of the ways that we
can be supportive to not only
individuals and their family members but
managers
work groups um at the policy level at
the individual level so so is it fair to
say that um kind of a quick summary of
this is that you have a total of seven
positions and you're serving all of the
uh state government yes sir okay um and
H has there been a change in the last
few years to the number of
positions I because I remember 14 for
some reason I don't know why I would
remember that
I've been in the director's role for two
years now and uh I started with the
program in 2015 I think the only
adjustment was there was a position
added and I would say that may have been
four years ago and you received revenues
from other depart uh other U functions
of the state to help pay for the EAP yes
sir I don't know okay all
right go ahead I'm sorry I just that
that's that's sort of my bottom line in
this your your service the entire State
you're getting revenue from them for
providing a service and you're doing it
with a what feels to me for the number
of people
serviced a relatively lean
staff do you want to argue with any that
no no no um we're passionate about the
work we do and uh you know when I think
about some of the experiences over the
last year you know some of the resources
as we kind of named our key
accomplishments is that we've increased
our satellite hours with two of the 247
facilities where we are available on
site uh a couple hours a week for
employees to kind of meet us in their
own workspace yeah and I think you know
just to be brief that that experience uh
was very instrumental and employees
feeling comfortable accessing Us in
particular crisis moments so I assume
that you have some kind of a metric that
you manage as as a director you have the
number of clients that you can
potentially serve divided by the number
of people to have a a metric on the
number of people serve per counselor you
probably have that we we we need to be
flexible around that because the nature
of the work is there can be uh sudden uh
events that occur that we all have to
kind of come together and be flexible
you have a base a base metric like that
I assume and and so we probably saw an
increase in the number of the volume of
requested Services yes during the
pandemic yes did you are you keeping
that metric too so that we can see post
pandemic what the demand is on the
services I I assume they're in a in a
decline do you have statistics in here
that they're not they're not in a
decline where there was a shift was that
the resources shifted during the
pandemic particularly in the early part
from face-to-face Services yeah and
training
uh but as a matter of fact the
complexity of the needs that folks have
are now in multiple areas where prior to
the pandemic they were kind of unique or
individual kinds of experiences okay so
in previous sessions we've tried to get
to to the informational aspects of the
department and what we're really after
in in these budget sessions yes is the
is your performance metrics okay what
what what kind of volume are we doing
what are we projecting for future volume
what's been the historical Trend we we
kind of need to know that sort of
performance metric Behavior so that we
can determine you know how how we're
doing so if the resources allocated are
appropriate for the function no I I can
appreciate that what I what I would say
around kind of the shift is we have and
I spoke about this at the last session
uh we we're moving towards a data
management system and we recently
adopted that which will allow us to
predict Trends and kind of more of a
proactive approach we began utilizing
that to capture trainings and
orientations and things of that nature
in September and individual client in
July and individual client information
in September and so for the last
calendar year I can share some
information around uh Services provided
if if that would be
helpful uh in terms of numbers served
okay that would that would be great
performance metrics that's that's the
code
so uh in the last calendar year we have
met with 750 individual clients or kind
of new
cases we have provided satellite office
hours to 2 247 facilities on
105 uh days over that year span so two
days a week we're there for two hours at
each location so that's 210 manh hours
by take multiplying it by two sites
that sounds right to me
yes uh 60 plus trainings that could have
been anywhere from one hour to four to
six hours on various topics uh not only
from a kind of a critical incident
response metric but part of the
evolution of the program is to uh lean
into the preventative and kind of
resiliency protective factors so 60 plus
trainings anywhere from 1 hour to 6
hours and
um 97 orientations which is either new
client orientations where we are there
presenting information or orientations
for managers and that's one of these
guides here around uh the unique
resources that are available for
managers or supervisors that we
offer okay
um this this is helpful being able to
see a trend and a projection would be
make this even more helpful I project I
I mean the projections moving forward
forward are that when we have a year two
years worth of data in the new data
management system we're not only going
to be able to see Trends but we're going
to be able to quantify the service
delivery models in much more articulated
ways than we've been able to with a
paper and Pen model do do you have a um
not and since we don't have a
quantitative projection do you have a
qualitative one do you have your own
prediction of what the next budget looks
like in terms of
demand I wouldn't I wouldn't want to uh
get a number without more thought there
that's fair do you have a question yeah
representative Neno um I have a very
quick question on page five uh and
that's what what is the definition of
peer support
groups yes thank you uh so so the peer
support model that we are supportive
around is uh there are a number of
different departments within the state
that recognize the need of being you
know uh being available or or employees
want to be supportive of their
colleagues because of a shared work
experience so for example law
enforcement's experience is may be very
different than other departments and so
they recognize their's value in a peer
support model uh and and in these
specific agencies the the challenges
that they deal with the events that they
deal with are very different from one
Department to the next and so we have
been instrumental and supporting
multiple de departments develop their
own peer support agency but also be a
resource for the peer supporters when
they are receiving uh information that's
beyond their scope and also to intervene
to support employees they might be
crossing paths with when the material is
at a higher level than say a a peer
support may be kind of qualified to be
available around just a quick followup f
is that um uh like an employee affinity
group I think that's a that's one way of
uh kind of describing it but there's
also training that happens there so it's
not just um you know people kind of
volunteering out of out of you know say
the goodness of their heart they have
some level of uh knowledge around trauma
or depending on what the unique
experiences of that work group might be
they may get a different kind of
training and we are not we are not the
ones who are providing that training uh
alone you know so for instance um State
Police has a peer support model and it
is modeled that after other states who
also have a similar model and do a lot
of that work internally but we are kind
of there as an ancillary support and
resource okay thank you thank you for
the response so so I have questions on
leveraging technology for productivity
are are you uh using any form of uh like
tele medicine to make yourselves more
accessible without
transportation we uh adapted to that
model uh during covid where we had to be
flexible around meeting people who
couldn't or wouldn't want to meet in
person and so that's certainly still a
model that we've used at the employees
request we we are available to uh All
State departments across the state and
certainly travel and meet folks where
they are but some folks whether it's
making a call during their lunch break
or wanting to meet face to face uh have
that option as well so I imagine
employees know that tele medicine is an
option absolutely when we do our
orientations or anywhere we're marketing
we're sharing the diverse ways that we
support folks and and then uh have you
placed any um training modules or
information modules on the States's
LMS we're in the process of uh
collaborating on a Model I'm not sure if
we I'd have to look back at some of my
research I know we often do partner with
internal a um say odts to provide
information and and so there may be some
material that are that's there right
because I'm just looking at this uh new
orientations for as an example and then
you got the 60 plus trainings I'm if it
feels like there should be a subset that
could go on LMS to enhance productivity
but but that's just a comment for you to
think about U uh and then I I I want to
know about surge you you started to talk
about if you had a spike for some reason
in cases that you needed to deal with
what what's your surge contingency do
you have subcontracts with anyone to to
to provide an expansion we do not have
subcontracts uh when I think about you
know this idea of a surge maybe or kind
of unanticipated event what comes to
mind is the response to uh the active
shooter event with New Hampshire
hospital and so uh we were we were one
of the groups being supportive of
employees in my estimation the fact that
we're available for satellite hours
there made us a a a nice option for
folks because they were familiar with us
but to your original question uh those
kinds of experiences have allowed us to
uh build Partnerships and relationships
so that when there are these
unanticipated events we can connect with
folks who are so did you see a big spike
in EAP requests uh in the aftermath of
that shooting at the New Hampshire
hospital yes I mean from from multiple
departments on you know so we we were
part of the response team to support
employees who were experiencing that
directly but there's multiple
departments on those State grounds that
were also uncertain and we hold that
information confidentially and
responding supporting them as well uh
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um this is
regarding kind of a continuation of what
um representative Edwards uh said asked
you about the contingency fund um I'm
very interested if whether whether or
not the the department and especially
your division has
a contingency if we have another
pandemic happening and what's going to
happen if that
occurs um ju just to clarify
representative priest um contingency
fund for what
purpose to cover the overtime the
additional staff needed to do your
purposes sure no the the department does
not have any specific contingency fund
for those purposes typically how we
would handle that if we did see an
excessive increase in overtime we would
seek to transfer uh the funds from some
other vacancy or contract that may be
UND spent or something to that effect um
and that kind of hearkens back to the
hb2 provision I was speaking to
yesterday relative to the ability to
transfer out of personnel lines that's
just an example of really where it's
really important for us to do that there
is a Statewide fund that other agencies
pay into that that could potentially
assist in those instances but HHS does
not pay into that historically because
we have that flexibility so when we do
have for example like an employee
retires after 45 years and they were a
really high paid employee like when we
have to pay out tens of thousands of
dollars we have to find that money
within our budget if there was an
emergency we'd have to do the same thing
thank
you uh back back to the kind of the
standard ones what what what's your
vacancy rate what's your what are your
issues relative to replacing somebody is
that a short spin up or is that a long
one and I guess in this case I'd like to
know what the general uh uh credential
background is for counselor
M yeah so currently we do not have any
vacancies um and the the kind of
onboarding experience you know when I
started with the EAP in 2015 my
predecessor used to say it takes about
three years to learn the job and um I
don't know if I would say it takes that
long but I think that there's a learning
curve regardless of what your background
is if you if you have a behavioral
health back ground that certainly can uh
support the onb boarding process with
certain aspects of the the position but
the position is also very complex in
terms of dealing with all departments
different cultures for every agency sure
so you don't you don't have like an RN
or behavioral specialist in their job
requirements and your job description we
don't I mean it it it used to be
Master's level only positions but
there's been some uh flexibility around
uh experience in
education okay okay i' I'd be curious in
in seeing that if you could just shoot
me the standard the job description
please yes okay I'm I'm I'm good
represent Wallen did you have anything
okay anyone all right I I I want to
thank you do you want to I I I tackled
you before you really got going so is
there anything you really want us to
hear that we haven't heard yet thank you
for your time all right thank you thank
you
so okay so next up this morning we will
have uh human
resources and uh the presentation should
be the next subsequent presentation in
your packet and in the in the governor's
budget book the accounting unit is on
page
1,56 just give folks a moment to turn
there
and it is accounting unit
5677 Bureau of human
resources and in the budget briefing
book it is located on page
25 thank you for the orientation
Mr weeders how are you today I am good
thank you representative and Mr chair um
members of the committee my name is
David weers I'm the Chief Operating
Officer for DHHS and I am here instead
of our HR Director as she is retiring at
the end of the month and I gave her the
day off um from this presentation I
didn't run her off with this budget
stuff did I I don't believe so all right
so I'm going to skip to slide three um
and I'll talk a little bit about our
mission as we go through but as the
human resources Bureau for the
Department we provide services across
all the 247 facilities as well as all of
the divisions for the department and
we're broken up into five different
specific areas uh the first one you'll
see is really managing our payroll and
benefits and in there we're we're really
focused on as everyone is sees it as
important is paying people in a timely
manner and accurately so that would be
one of the main components of that job
Duty as well as compliance with state
and federal laws and Personnel rules we
work with and partner with um Department
of administrative services for that work
and utilizing the the New Hampshire
first enterprise resource planning tool
for all of our
transactions and then we also partner
with the union and the collective
bargaining agreement that really puts
around all those rules and guidelines
for payroll and benefits and then moving
into and just as a comment um because
our predecessors talked about people in
the different areas we have 10 people
working in payroll and benefits and then
moving into workforce management we have
three people working there and that's
really focusing on developing and
maintaining the workforce and ensuring
that they have the necessary tools to
meet their jobs um you'll probably hear
terms like supplemental job descriptions
making sure that they have their job
description and their objectives
identified and then working on
Innovative creative and Sustainable
Solutions to really move forward so this
group um in partnership with again
administrative Services is working on
the
reclassifications of all of the
positions across the state um in our
specific area across HR across
DHHS and the employee relations and
engagement we have again three people
working in there uh right now we have a
the whole Workforce is out and so we
have one person that resigned so that
one's vacant another one that is out on
medical leave and the third one actually
we do have a third Tech that is working
in there so we're operating at 2/3 down
in that group and that that group
focuses on Ada
management as well as any type of
employee relations question so anytime
someone calls up and has an issue with
what's going on with their supervisor or
the supervisor having challenges with
their staff they provide that
support oh sorry I just heard an Echo
come back on me um then moving to slide
four we have our organizational
development and Training Services and as
we if you look at your budget there's a
training line in that training line
budget we have five people that work
throughout the department to provide
leadership training mentorship training
and then also supervisor hiring manager
training and then professional
development opportunities like you heard
from Mike Lawless regarding um EAP
supporting um other divisions like that
did you have something to add
employee oh sorry EAP employee
assistance program so I'm trying not to
use my three-letter acronyms or tlas so
Nathan will keep me honest on
those
um and then in our final area within the
bureau we have our talent acquisition
and in our talent Acquisitions really
focus on Recruitment and Retention so
you'll see throughout the this
presentation some of the efforts that
we've taken to try to not only just
recruit people effectively using um best
practice tools and Partnerships with
administrative services but also
retention practices to keep those people
here
so are you through with that intro you
ready for questions sure okay um so um
it was the case six seven years ago that
this we relied the DHHS relied on the
state um website for people to come in
externally to find out what jobs are
vacant and to begin the application
process
and that system was horrible and I I
know that uh it had been a goal of uh
the commissioner
doit to upgrade that what what what do
you think our current status is in terms
of having a
state-of-the-art
um marketing to the public so that they
can find out which jobs they may uh be
interested and qualify for in a nice
clean elegant way certainly so we
partnered with administrative services
on a Statewide agreement um for
different Marketing Solutions like
indeed.com and Linkedin I'm sorry you
said who ADP indeed I
heard um and then LinkedIn as well as
other
Solutions um it still remains that the
majority of our applicants come through
the state New Hampshire first postings
um that's where people have shown up and
were able to um make their applications
however ever we've had about another
half again applicants coming in through
indeed.com which has been a very
successful solution of being able to
recruit different staff um when it comes
to the LinkedIn solution we haven't has
much much success there there's a couple
components to that LinkedIn um has
multiple subscriptions um that you can
add on that can really advance that and
it's really focused or we've seen seen
it being really focused on some of those
professional um executive level type
positions that we're not recruiting for
so we've seen most of our success in our
New Hampshire first Erp system or
enterprise resource planning system and
the indeed.com
subscription okay are should we be
satisfied with the way that we're using
it to Market and begin the first
introduction to to each other I think
there's ongoing um components of our
road map where we're engaging our our
customers more effectively and trying to
see how we can recruit more effectively
through social media uh platforms as
well and so that's something that you
would I would anticipate our growth
growth area to be in in the next couple
years is the money for something like
that in the HR budget or over somewhere
in the it budget it would be over in the
it budget however the the component for
the indeed.com partnership with
administrative Services was submitted in
our agency phase but is not represented
in the Governor's phase budget so it's
about
$102,000 that you would see that was not
did not make it to the governor's budget
so you're $12k light on indeed.com
upgrades is that what you just said um
indeed.com subscriptions Mr chair and so
if we don't have that money do you
terminate the subscription and then we
make it on something else without those
funds we would be reverting back to the
Legacy solution of just relying on the
state
um system the state Erp system so I
assume the governor's office looked
carefully at the the metrics around how
indeed is paying paying off for us and
and making this decision or do we need
to relook that
independently I can't speak for the
governor's office however we did provide
some of the metrics regarding the do you
want to say anything about that Mr White
do do do you know the basis of uh
decision not to fund in indeed.com
subscription no I I I don't recall
specific details around this particular
item all right thank you question
Stringham and then priest yeah the
question I have is around the hiring
practices um uh I believe um last
bium uh the since there was an overall
uh limit to the number of employees that
we uh that were authorized despite the
number of approved positions being
higher uh the practice was to uh not
even
begin um uh promoting the availability
of of an approved position until you
knew that say if the person came in was
eligible qualified and you wanted to
hire them they could be hired the next
day was that still the practice or do
you are you now able to actively recruit
even though you may have to delay them
coming in because of the um uh ceing of
the number of employees sure so so Ju
Just to provide a little bit of History
here for for other members um so in the
current bium we have in in the back of
hb1 it's like page 700 or something
there is there is the the back of the
budget cut for HHS and within that back
of the budget cut there's two components
one is a reduction of General funds um
23 million in change but that reduction
is allowed to be a across the board so
not just limited to personnel and
there's also the second component that
is a 3,000 position cap that's for the
current bium in the in the prior bium
there was a personnel only in the amount
I think it was like 22.6 million
personnel only as well as the 3,000
position cap are um the in the current
by any with the back of the budget that
had more flexibility it hasn't impacted
hiring in the same way that it did in
the prior bium so in the prior bium
coming out of that I think in December
of 2022 we were looking at about a 22%
vacancy rate after being under that and
hiring freeze during the pandemic um
currently we're at
14.65 last I checked so that's about
2,800 positions so we we haven't had any
risk of yet bumping up to that 3,000 cap
um that currently expires June 30th of
2025 so a followup would be um so are
you able to promote the availability of
every position that's authorized at this
time that that is vacant or do you still
feel restricted in that so so there's
there's um there's two factors right now
that are different than the position we
were in a month ago um the first being
is that um the governor has issued an
executive order that puts a hiring free
on non-direct care positions And so
there's that component that we need to
balance here and we need to make sure
that you know when looking at Statewide
expenses that's a that's a serious
consideration and there's a process for
that and the governor's team is involved
in that and overseeing it the second
component that we're currently sitting
in that you know is very much on our
mind and we'll work with the committee
through this is currently our budget
effective July 1 looks like it has about
394 positions that are unfunded and so
we're also Dave and I I don't know how
many hours we've spent it on already I
mean we've we' also been looking at this
trying to find an effective way to make
sure that care direct care is not
impacted and it's a bit of a balancing
act because we are anticipating that
we're not going to have the Personnel
funds come July 1 that we have in the
current
bium representative
priest thank you Mr chairman I have
several questions the first one again
going back to a question that was
offered by chairman uh Edwards my
understanding was it cost
$102,000 for the indeed
subscription for the
Department y that's what they
said that correct thank you for the
question sorry for the delay the the
$102,000 is a projected cost of our our
cost associated with the Statewide
agreement partnership with
administrative Services indeed
specifically is 7200
44 of that okay and then there was a a
projected cost increase of
$988 that brings that up and then we
were planning to participate at a
reduced level on the LinkedIn contract
for the remainder amount okay thank you
and the next question is um regarding
page five of your handout could you give
us again the number of positions in each
each one of these five um divisions
please
sure
so I have
it my apologies for the the we so under
Lori spring for Workforce Development we
have three okay under and de for
employee relations and engagement
we have three as well okay under
organizational development and Training
Services we have
five under payroll and
benefits we have 10 and under Talent
acquisition we have another five and
then the remaining ones that you do not
see on this screen are we have three
over in New Hampshire hospital managing
their Recruitment and Retention and
employee relations as a whole not just
one area but they they manage the
hospital and then we have one additional
um HR position over a glen Cliff home
managing the gamut of everything at Glen
cff home uh the the last question is on
page uh
1047 of the governor's Budget on item
050 Personnel services- temp
slappointment or something um could
could you explain to me why there's this
variation of
$3,000 between
2,24 to
2025 just to be clear you meant 1047
because
1047 not in
that is is that a different department
that's a different department no we're
not okay I'll come back to the
okay because I I think they I we HR is
uh starting at 1056 okay thank you all
right U representative
seor thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like
to clarify something going back to that
102k it sounded like about
20K has to do with the LinkedIn contract
which is a Statewide
initiative did I hear that correct that
is correct so and that that wasn't
funded by the governor so it sounds to
me like at least that portion is a much
bigger item than just what we had before
this committee
because you couldn't just pay your 20K
and go get your LinkedIn it has to be
that the state continues with what it's
doing as a whole and you would ship in
for your share am I hearing that right
that is a fair um assumption we have we
are partnership with Department of
administrative services and they
basically part um work across all
agencies and our share of that is about
20,000 we have we are negotiations
telling and basically indicating to them
when they're talking to LinkedIn we're
going to be pulling out because we can't
we don't see two things one is it's not
in our budget and two we weren't seeing
the actual productivity of utilizing
those funds in that area in that
direction so those are ongoing
discussions
um sometimes when you start pulling out
from a vendor they might reduce their
costs um but that that both the LinkedIn
and the indeed are part of a Statewide
agreement go ahead so then what I said
kind of applies to both that if for
whatever reason on the Statewide level
that money is just
unavailable then
really hhs's portion of it isn't
possible unless the state renegotiates
that and has the funding for it if I
understand your question if the funding
from the Statewide perspective is
removed from the budget then all
agencies portions would also need to be
removed right that was my better said
that was what I was asking go ahead Mr
White the the alternative and and and
just to clarify so so it's 102,000 um in
each state fiscal year it's about 68% %
General funds of the total um I think uh
two quick things one is to to Dave's
Point around assessing the services that
we received we prepared these numbers
back in August um alternatively if this
if the department of administrative
Services didn't move forward with that
that wouldn't necessarily prohibit the
department from finding a solution uh
towards recruitment just you know and
I'm thinking in terms of we need to make
sure that we have nurses at New
Hampshire hospital because it's going to
cost us twice as much to get contracted
agency staff um same thing at Glen Cliff
same thing at the Youth Development
Center where we've had to rely on
contracted staff and then it creates pay
inequities between the employees that
actually work there so there's a number
of sort of Downstream effects and I I
wouldn't I I I wouldn't necessarily say
that because they didn't move forward
I'm not saying they shouldn't but I'm
saying that if they didn't move forward
I think strategically we would still
want to think about what are the
downstream impacts to the individuals
that we serve in our general
operations so I'm I'm going to go to you
represent Daniels just a second but a
followup to your comment there that's an
outstanding Point you're making we we it
costs us boatloads to do uh prum's
contract U nurses and the like and uh
and so as you come back because I'd like
some more information around the impact
of this missing
102,000 i' I'd like to understand what
what you all your experience has been
with using these tools to to recruit RNs
because with with RNs I think that's
more of a national search because I feel
like we've fished New Hampshire out and
we need to be bringing people in that's
that's my assumption of our Workforce
with
nurses
that's yeah you're you're off I switched
it sorry we certainly can go back and
get that information for you Mr chair
okay um and then I'm going to go to
representative Daniels and I'm but I'm
going to close by asking you what other
critical it systems are needed for HR
but but go ahead thank you could you
could you please State uh to what
specific uh classifications the 3000 cap
applies so the the 3000 um cap it was
for full-time authorized positions so
that includes your classified employees
and your unclassified employees um those
employees their salaries are represented
in class 12 the unclassified and Class
10 for the the permanent full-time
authorized employees and that and that
cap um was was applied to to those
specific positions which are rough
roughly 2800 filled last I checked okay
thank
you represent Alan um thank you for
taking the question I have a couple of
quick questions uh does HR have a uh
probationary policy with regard to new
hars and if so what's the length of that
probationary period and roughly at any
given time you know average number of
people on on
probation so yes there is a probationary
period for classified employees and I
I'm going to look to jna really quick I
believe it's is it 6 months or
12 it's initially 12 months for the F
for the first hire of that classified
employee so that's a long time yeah
that's a yeah that's a long time and and
and just to clarify that's not a
Department of Health and Human Services
rule that that that that's a collective
State rule that applies to all state
employees as far as that year to become
certified okay so it applies to the HR
section of DHHS uses that we we we
comply with the division of personnel
rules that are issued by the Department
administrative services division of
personnel um and okay and so the
probationary period U is for cause or
for any
reason um somebody on probationary
period could be let go is that an at
will
situation I I can take that back and get
the exact answer but it is similar to an
at will but there are other components
of the collective bargaining agreement
that we would have to follow so it's not
as straightforward
as okay as goodbye the answer one other
additional question in
the uh organizational development and
Training Services area is that inhouse
or does that involve a mix of In-House
uh uh training and and uh contract
saving uh and and if it's
uh involving contractors is some of that
money in a different different
area it it is there is a line item in
your budget so under 066 on the page
1056 of the of the budget there's
$273,000 in there and that's for
materials uh as well as supplies and and
if needed contractors but we do have the
organizational development team does the
majority of the curriculum building and
the training of those of those work but
they leverage those funds to subscribe
to Solutions um for like leadership type
training materials um similar to like if
you've heard of disk training where you
you get a specific focused group and you
organize people together to understand
their learning their learning process
and how they learn so that you can bring
people together more effectively I'm not
doing its justice but it is all in house
work
so so just a quick followup that that
wouldn't Encompass like something like
peer groups that we heard in the
EAP uh program no it wouldn't Encompass
peer groups it it's really that budget
there is focus on materials and supplies
and subscriptions to to tools and and
and materials but they if there's peer
Group Training there is training
throughout the department for specific
functions like child support and uh
child welfare and EAP where they would
have their own budget for those training
um Information Services has a training
budget for project management for for
for um example and also would it be you
know a burden to possibly have a look at
some of the training materials if yeah
we certainly should be able to send you
links to it as well as um documents yeah
link you you might want to be more clear
on which training material you're
looking
they probably have a tremendous range of
trainings in this area that may be good
because for example like we have
trainings on how to read a statement of
Appropriations it's certainly not the
most exciting of trainings I'm more than
willing to share it but is there a
specific okay so so um um ancient
corporate experience we used to have a
management level sensitivity training is
that is that an area that we still so to
get to the nub of that this is another
probe around Dei do do do have we
screened these materials to make sure
that those classic components of Dei
training are not part of our training
program we have screened to make sure
that there isn't Dei specifics however
we have like code of conduct and ethics
training so that people manage privacy
of materials sure but we're not training
people that they're inherently in ior if
they're a particular race or
gender not that I know of but I will
validate that statement and that sort of
thing you know so and then was that
really yeah thanks for that thanks for
the more direct uh that's all right
point I I think the subject's been
broached we can probably just talk about
it directly um do you have any
other okay so so um as I'm looking at
the numbers as you went around the five
ele
I think I counted 30 uh FTE but when I
go look at the governor's recommended I
I'm seeing uh 32 up one from 31 and I'm
just wondering if as you went around the
wheel telling us how many you had in
each block uh if we missed to I I I
believe what's missing is the director
and and deputy director position from
that total count okay that would explain
it um and then um what other
critical uh it systems are there I I
don't need the Ash and trash like
Microsoft but but are there some key uh
components of the HR department that
rely on a specific it system I would say
there's three key ones so the first one
is New Hampshire first which is M
migrating to Cloud Suite which is the
Statewide enterprise resource planning
tool um managed and operated by um
administrative Services yeah and so that
one is where we do all of our
transactions for every area then we also
um funded in bis the learning management
system that you heard about earlier so
this is where the core of the LMS
expenses for the entire department the
LMS expense is actually in the um Bureau
of Information Services um budget but
this team manages the LMS so HR is
responsible for managing this system
good and it utilizes um hundreds of
different um training components that we
do screen and and validate the content
that is in there and allow for anyone in
the workforce to utilize including
annual compliance for policies and
procedures and standard uh components
like sexual harassment training ethics
training what else and then the the
third one is essentially a combination
of two things the Enterprise business
intelligence platform is where we manage
all of our data we actually get an
extract from the cloud Suite solution
the Erp solution into that and then we
have an access database which is our H
HR or human resources headcount database
so that combined with ebi we use that
for our data analytics for for um
understanding our vacancy rates
understanding our turnover rates and
managing our our statistics
H that sounds like a good application
it's definitely
helpful okay and of course you heard
about the the other one which was our
recruitment platform of leveraging um
indeed as well as the State website all
right okay and then standard questions
what what is your vacancy rate and how
long does it take to train up a new
person so we currently have and we have
eight full-time vac and two part-time
vacants right now out of the staff so
that's rough math about 30% low over and
what is the organizational impact what
are you guys not doing that's critical
as a result of being down I I I would
just say that we are keeping up but
barely um so the areas that are having
some challenges in in terms of response
time is employee relations Ada requests
are taking longer because we're down
2third of that Workforce we are able to
maintain payroll and benefits however
we're delayed on workforce management in
terms of being able to ensure that we
have enough resources to support that
and then over in our organizational
development and training we are short a
number of staff there including the
administrator which is reducing our
ability to perform training Solutions
across the department those trainings
are critical for managing to creating
better leadership better supervisory SK
skills so that we can actually retain
our staff right and so that that's
really the impact and and currently
there are six positions that were
unfunded in this in this budget and
you'll see that reduction in class 10
and
60 did you have a question
representative wner I saw a hand gesture
over there no okay do you need
it the the six positions that are
unfunded are including in included in
the 10 vacancy
yes
okay okay are there any other questions
for from the
members uh okay again I I made you
Hopscotch all over your presentation is
there anything critical uh that we need
to know from a resource allocation
perspective that that we've not
mentioned I think we covered it I mean
there's statistics in there that you can
peruse at your own time but we covered
all the information for the HR thank you
okay again my theory on this is that we
tried to spend time before uh the budget
arrived dealing with what does a
department do um and how it does it and
now we're really trying to focus on what
kind of resources and performance
metrics are there to um for us to know
how we're doing so so that's that's sort
of why I'm I'm um sabotaging the the the
presentations getting straight to the
point on resource allocation so thank
you for your patience uh you you you did
very well for somebody who's not steeped
in HR so thank you thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee
okay uh next up division of program
quality and integrity and if you can get
us oriented between the three documents
okay sure so if you it should just be
the next uh presentation in order in
front of you and the there's two
accounting units that are associated
with this um Division and they're in two
different locations which is not the
easiest thing but we'll we'll work
through it so the first in the
governor's operating budget is on page
[Music]
1,46 and this is accounting unit
7935 the second accounting unit if you
turn a few pages
forward is on page
[Music]
1,61 again
1,61 and it's accounting unit
37 and if you open up the budget
briefing
book it will be on
page sec
I think I missed
it
no cu 14 thank you it's 14 7935 yes and
then there's another one another page
for
6637 I'll find it
go so we'll get started while Nathan is
looking for the second page of the
budget briefing book good morning my
name is Meredith tus I'm the director of
our division of program quality and
integrity for the
Department uh and I'm going to go
through our presentation I'm not going
to read you all the slides slides but
I'll be giving you kind of an overview
and orientation to the information on
each of the slides knowing that those
are sort of reference materials you can
go back to so starting on slide
two of the presentation our role as a
division is to provide support to
Department programs to measure and
Achieve quality and maintain Integrity
in their day-to-day work so we are a
support division is really one of the
most important uh components of our
division we exist in order to support
all of the other divisions and the
programs and functions that they are are
doing in order to directly impact the
people of New
Hampshire that's really our role in the
department and the way in which we do
that is described in detail on slides
three and four so moving to slide
three can can I ask you a question there
y go ahead please okay so in the
division of finance they also have an
audit function do do you perform
different types of audits how how how do
we maintain a distinction go
ahead no you go ahead sure so when I say
audit it's different from the audit
function that Meritt is going to talk
about what we do for audit is we work
with um the the various Auditors it
might be the LBA it might be a federal
audit it might be the single audit uh
the team Works closely with the Auditors
to prepare and Meritus team to prepare
the documents um for their requests and
work them work with them on any finding
potential findings or
recommendations so I I will describe it
but we do audits in my division we also
work as a liaison when we get audits so
when there's an external entity doing a
review of the department my team would
work as a liaison to make sure that the
documentation that's being given to the
Auditors is the right kind of
documentation that they're requesting we
kind of think of ourselves as people who
speak audit so when an auditor comes and
says I need something from you we're
going to look at the documentation and
say yeah this is what they're asking for
or no no no you haven't gotten what
they're asking for actually and then
when we get reports we'll actually go
through the report with the audit the
audit being probably Nathan's team and
say all right how are you going to
respond to the these findings how are
you going to mitigate these
findings and and okay and so implied in
that is if you have previous Audits and
you've got findings and you have open
findings you're the one actively
managing the closure of a finding that's
right all right it's exactly
right slide
three one of our primary functions is
data management and Analysis so we
manage data sets and we work with others
across the department and external
stakeholders to ensure that our data as
a department is clean clear actionable
and correctly interpreted by those who
are using it to make decisions for
example we manage the mqi Medicaid
quality information system uh which
reports on hundreds of Medicaid quality
metrics we also work on Medicaid waivers
um the evaluations of those uh we work
on Behavioral Health and sud data
develop and we we help develop
performance metrics for any kind of
individual program but a lot of our
Focus areas are Medicaid Behavioral
Health and
sud we also designed methods for vendor
and contract management both
programmatic and financial uh and that's
and we also develop Audits and reviews
for our contractors and vendors that are
both programmatic and financial and in
some cases we do those reviews ourselves
and in other instances we're just
helping to develop the tools and the
platform and then working with program
areas so that they can go and do those
kinds of reviews
themselves slide
four we conduct a number of activities
for the purpose of federal compliance um
that includes internal audits or reviews
that were required to do per Federal
Regulation um such as the Medicaid
Eligibility quality control audit uh
Child Care reviews uh what's called our
quality assurance reviews and our
special investigations unit I'll go into
more detail on what they do when I get
to the descriptions of our individual
Bureau activities but those are just
some examples I I want to develop the
mental picture in my head around what a
compliance methodology would be for
federal and state laws regulations and
guidance I'm assuming some kind of thing
that looks like an Excel spreadsheet
with 10,000 line items on it that you
have to comply with 10,000 requirements
and you've got a source of why it's a
requirement and you've got some sort of
inspection date where you verified it
and whether or not we're in compliance
or we got a problem is it is it is it
that mechanical or is it more elegant it
it it's by program area so for examp
example for Medicaid we work on the perm
audit which is the payment error rate
methodology audit so we have Auditors
that come into the state and they're
looking at both eligibility and claims
one by one they do they have a sampling
methodology that they use and then we're
working with them on the outcome of that
in order to make sure that we're in
compliance for each of their findings
for the mqc that's an audit that we do
ourselves that's Medicaid Eligibility
quality and for that it it is similar
for child care and for it it depends on
the review that we're doing but yes
there are Excel spreadsheets involved
where we take samples of individual
cases and payments we go through and we
say what was done correctly what was not
done correctly and then we have to feed
the information back to the program area
to say here's where you need to make
adjustments it may or may not be a
report that we then have to report to
the feds um so we' take our Excel
spreadsheet package it into a report and
tell the feds this isn't what we found
but in any instance we would go back to
the program area and say this is what we
found and here are the changes you need
to make to be in compliance uh would you
ever or have you ever taken a look at
the state compliance requirements and
gone to the legislature to ask for
relief of compliance measures that don't
really add
value we would do that as part of an
internal AUD I mean I think on a case-by
casee basis program areas do that on a
regular basis because program areas are
constantly looking at what they're doing
and whether or not they have the
resources to comply with their
requirements right I think we have an
appetite to get uh more get less
compliant facing requirements to you and
and and to to give to liberate the
department increase flexibility as long
as it isn't violating you know U patient
privacy or you know so so you're the one
that's buried deep in that mud and if
you ever see things that we're doing
that just doesn't really add value would
you would you please bring them forward
we certainly would and and like I said I
think program areas do that on their own
as well the legislation that we bring
forward every year is intended to
improve our our capabilities there also
say you know our LBA audits make
recommendations and we look at those Rec
for sometimes for uh changes to
legislation and we look to those and and
would find sponsors and bring things
forward where we think it's appropriate
super who who has a question over here
represent thank you chairman and thank
you for taking the question so on page
three it refers to Quality Medicaid data
so um you know excuse me if I'm kind of
naive on the whole issue of you know
data so you're relying on the accuracy
of a of a Medicaid database or um and to
the extent that uh there are may be
problems with that what what does that
what kind the problems is that pose at
the state
level so we're relying on a couple
different areas we have our Medicaid
encounter data that comes directly from
our Managed Care organizations that's
our that's our encounter our claims data
is used to build out our Medicaid
quality metrics and I may call on Susan
drown uh our bureau chief for the Bureau
of program quality to see if she has
anything to
add do you want to add to this question
Ju Just repeat or answer
go
ahead
yeah good morning Susan drown you have
that you have to put that in the
record he is in Delta R
WN I'm the director of the Bureau of
program quality so the the the Medicaid
data that's coming in just to be clear
on what that's referencing is to the
Managed Care Organization data that gets
submitted and then it gets filtered into
the Medicaid quality information system
that's public
facing so is there a question on the
accuracy of the data yes could you get
the mic really close to your mouth sure
absolutely so we have quality control
and quality assurance when the data
comes in we look at it but also the
Managed Care
organizations um are also authorized to
do their own and required to do their
own data validation much of that data
gets submitted to to CMS every year so
they have an independent company that
comes in the manag care organizations do
to Ure the the reliability of their data
yep so it's it's a great question I will
say that when we first started our
Managed Care Program there was an issue
with I think one particular vendor's um
accuracy of their encounter data and it
took a few years to work that out but uh
we have a very very diligent individual
who worked with them for that period of
time and and to this at this point we
are confident in the accuracy of that
data we also do have a uh what's
referred to as an eqro an external EQ
external quality review
organization um an EQ which is which is
a federally required review process that
looks at that data for accuracy and
they're a vendor of of ours not of the
Managed Care organizations okay thanks
thanks for the response sure as long as
we're on all that data stuff um um I I
assume that by and large your department
dabbles in the it systems that are
functionally aligned or or do you have a
particular it system that that you rely
on we have many it systems that we rely
on and many places that the data is held
primarily belong functionally to other
parts of the organization or do you
basically are you the owner of any it
systems uh I would say that we are it's
a bit shared ownership but I would say
that we might be the owner of a couple
different it systems I'm thinking of
Phoenix and witz would you call us the
it owners of those
systems okay but like us as opposed to
um it's it belongs to behavioral
health okay so we are the we are the
data managers of these systems but they
are owned by the program areas
okay yeah okay and that's that's
definitely the case with mmis which is
where we do a lot of our work but that's
of course owned by Medicaid got it yeah
so so so just so we have some time
context uh I think we're on track to end
by noon right yes definitely okay that's
21 minutes
absolutely uh
slide I think we can skip to slide five
five which is a very high level overview
of the three functions within the
division our office of internal audit
Bureau of program quality and Bureau of
program integrity and slide six just
lists out some key accomplishments of
each of the sections over the last
bium uh uh representative priest thank
you Mr chair
how many uh staff do you have in each of
these
four divisions on on five page five the
my position is the director position at
the top do you have a deputy I do not
okay and then an office of internal
audit I have two individuals okay in the
Bureau of program quality I have
33 that include the
unclassified that doesn't include
part-time that's full-time that's
full-time do you have a number of
part-time we have two one one one in the
Bureau of program quality okay and in
the Bureau of program Integrity we have
71 full-time
positions and nine part-time how many
vacancies do you have
currently I don't think I can answer
that I I we we would have to get that
information there are six unfunded
positions six unfunded okay yes three in
the Bureau of program integrity and
three in the Bureau of program quality
unfunded so without telling us a vacancy
number because you don't have it are are
you
U is your program operation
being significantly negatively impacted
by a vacancy
by the by the UNF funding by the no not
the unfund but but just by have your
operational vacancy today we we will be
if we can't fill those positions the
three in the Bureau of program
quality are vacant partly because we
were sort of remodeling a particular
section which we need in order to be
able to move forward with our data
analytics and Reporting
and because some there are some internal
moves with that if I'm not going to be
able to fill those positions then I'm
going to end up for example having an
individual who needs to do two jobs and
that that's going to be problematic for
performance what kind of position is
that in general is that a a mid-level p
position or is that somebody with steep
subject matter expertise this is someone
with deep subject matter expertise who
has moved into a mid-level manager
position and so now I'm I'm not going to
be able to backfill her position
all right representative Daniels yes and
how long have those positions been
vacant uh well this one is very recent
this person just moved with part these
positions were created from positions
that we had we used our existing
positions and and reorg made a new org
structure in order to be able to move
forward uh so the positions were created
within the last six months or however
long it took to create these
positions so I I I do have some vacancy
data it it's about a month old um this
moves every day but the bureau program
Integrity um was at about 8.8% Bureau
program quality was at about
11.4% vacancy as of about a month
ago which is which is lower than the
Department's overall average just to be
clear as well as the
states okay any other uh represent Incas
no thank you very much welcome back you
have any
questions I apologize apparently in
ledge edmin they run schedule like the
Senate does and squeeze it all in so I
apologize thank you um all right you can
continue slide
six I'll just provide a few highlights
off of this page we migrated to a new
5-year MCO contract which included
reviewing and revising the Quality
Reporting measures and writing a new
updated quality strategy for the Managed
Care Program we established standardized
contract assessment tools for each phase
of the contract life cycle we closed out
four LBA audits in transparent New
Hampshire and we reduced the entire
backlog of claims and investigations for
beneficiary fraud and overpayments to
below
10% uh we also reduced the number of
single audit findings from about 23 uh
back in like pre-2020 days to just five
uh in the most recent audit and working
with our Bureau of family assistance we
helped them to reduce our snap error
rate supplemental nutritious Access
program uh error rate to just over 8%
which is below the national
average slide seven this slide just
details some of the functions of our
office of internal
audit they conduct quality assurance
reviews which are reviews looking for
areas of risk and making recommendations
to reduce risk and improve operational
efficiencies they investigate potential
fraudulent or unethical Behavior Uh they
ensure compliance with transparent New
Hampshire and they act as the liazon for
LBA audits so they will track those and
make sure that we're responsive during
the audit and that we follow up on any
findings slide eight so so um
investigating potentially fraudulent or
unethical behavior um do do you have any
uh metrics that you you can share with
us to tell us um the results of these
kind of Investigations are are we uh how
clean are we as a and these are internal
these are internal to the department
it's not to our vendors correct correct
these are internal to the department I
can tell you that there are not there
are not many investigations every year
there are very few and that the general
finding is that there was uh what I will
characterize as poor judgment rather
than fraudulent behavior all
right good to
know uh slide
eight the Bureau of program Integrity
consists of six individual units uh and
a supporting administrative section each
unit there has a unique function but
they're all aligned in that they provide
oversight and guidance to our program
areas to ensure uh operation and
financial compliance or to reduce fraud
or to minimize waste so we do this by
working with our our program areas
working with our external stakeholders
and working with our federal partners
and the special investigations unit
establishes claims for overpayments and
they investigate potential beneficiary
or member fraud our program Integrity
unit works with our mcos to the Managed
Care organizations to analyze claims for
potential fraud waste and abuse and
recover overpayments our Medicaid
provider enrollment unit conducts site
visits and they do background checks and
screenings for provider owners and
managing directors to ensure um
Integrity of the Medicaid Program our
thirdparty liability unit uh also works
very closely with our Managed Care
organizations to ensure Medicaid's the
pair of Last Resort our quality
assurance unit conducts reviews of snap
eligibility determinations for accuracy
and our financial Compliance Unit
completes financial analysis including
audits or reviews of of our providers
and then works with with program areas
to strengthen our response to Federal
Audits and then we have an
administrative support unit and they um
take payment on recoveries and they
assist with all areas of data
analysis for that Bureau so so I'm
interested in all of these but these
first the top two uh kind of jump out at
me special investigations and and
Medicaid Program Integrity I I think
other states periodically report you
know massive findings of fraud
and I just wonder where where you think
New Hampshire Stacks in terms of of um
put the what we what we would perceive
to be our vulnerability to
fraud uh I know that we we punch above
our weight in terms of recoveries and
investigations in that we we don't do uh
we find potential fraud and then we make
the referral to the Department of
Justice Medicaid fraud control unit and
the Medicaid fraud control unit in every
state is responsible for actually
investigating and pursuing
fraud in New Hampshire uh they have um I
think they are less funded compared to
the scale of the Medicaid Program but in
the last uh three or four years they
have had a number of uh criminal
convictions and also uh civil civil
penalties and recoveries and I'm going
to look at Franchesca Hennessy to make
sure see if she has anything to
add in terms
of you have a seat at the end and uh
turn the mic on
red good
morning my name is Franchesca Hennessy I
work under Meredith too I'm the fraud
waste and abuse administrator so program
Integrity which is our Medicaid provider
Fraud Unit falls under me which I think
is what you were asking about and yes
there is uh fraud that we've identified
um mostly in certain areas we
investigate it we refer it to the um
Attorney General's office which Meredith
referenced um and they've had a number
of large
recoveries okay so so a question that's
not an official answer but what is in
your gut what what sort of percentage of
our Medicaid spend do you think may be
going out in in in probable fraudulent
manners
honestly I don't feel comfortable giving
a percentage however I can give you some
solid information we have 50 around 50
cases at the Medicaid fraud control unit
right now that they're investigating and
that's cases that we manag that were
coming from the mcos that we've
investigated from our feif for service
program so cases um that weren't paid
through our mcos so that's 50 providers
I mean we have over 30,000 providers in
the whole Medicaid Program so it's not a
huge number but the amount of recoveries
that we will recover from our closed
cases show that there are large
recoveries and fraud does happen I don't
know if that helps at all there are many
if I can just add some context there are
many many more instances of what we
would refer to as waste or abuse over
payments and that's where a lot of the
money is so this is an instance of poor
billing practices at a provider we
identify that we stop it from happening
and we recover the money
and and that is that is in the the
millions Mr W could you remind me what
what the uh the total spend on Medicaid
is for a year that it's a bunch of money
it it depends how you count it um but in
in the Medicaid budget if I recall
correctly for the for the banum it was
2.7 billion just shot 2.7 billion in the
Governor's operating budget so so
Meredith you're you're speaking in terms
of millions M which makes it imply that
it's a relatively small percentage it's
5% maybe or less are you kind of
comfortable with that characterization
yes okay you're doing God's work thank
you thank you the staff really is
they're very enthus we have a very
enthusiastic staff who investigates both
on the member side and the provider side
so you guys enjoy busting people good
well they enoy they enjoy ensuring the
Integrity of the program and that money
is going where it's supposed to go thank
you so much service all
right slide nine is just a graphic
representation that we created so that
you
would yeah a couple couple of quick
questions on it the graph on BPI
recovery of overpayments two two
questions there so you identify
overpayments and this is what you
recover is this uh uh so what percentage
of over does this represent of
overpayments the you know what what how
much is
unrecovered uh in some instances the
mcos may choose to figure out how much
they're going to be able to recover from
a provider th this this is not this is
from sorry let me clarify this is what
we the Bureau of program Integrity would
recover from any source so this is
Medicaid snap
uh general fund any any kind of
beneficiary or provider overpayment that
we would receive this is not uh
necessarily fraud which is recovered by
the
doj and this is not this is not
represent what's recovered by our
Managed Care organizations our Managed
Care organizations keep what they
recover and then when we develop our man
Managed Care rates we have reduced the
rate that they're going to get by the
amount they have recovered so if they
negotiate some kind of payment plan with
a provider we are still looking at the
total amount of overpayment and we are
reducing that from our rate okay and
then the second follow-up question if
you don't mind question is okay so
that's where part of the recovery goes
recovery is there recovery money in any
line item here where where is recovery
money that comes back to
dhss show up it's either unrestricted
Revenue
or it goes back to the federal
government and and just to tack onto
that so the the money that is recovered
100% does not go back to the state so
there are portions that may go to the
federal government they may go to
counties as well um we provided a
presentation and I can share it with the
committee to house Ways and Means um
that kind of details the types of
recoveries that that DHHS engages in and
the total amounts uh by type each year
so so that shows up in a line item
someplace uh it's it's unrestricted
Revenue so it goes back to the general
coffers of the state it's not it it it
doesn't get designated as a revenue
Source in like a specific accounting
unit here to the best of my knowledge
and I can verify that so it's not so
it's not budgeted for it correct it h
when it happens it it winds up in the
general fund but it's not in the budget
it it is it is in the budget um it so
when house Ways and Means comes up with
their projections and their revenue
sources the the 3.1 million that we have
budgeted in 26 and 27 will be budgeted
in that amount so when the LBA develops
their Surplus statement those other
recoveries will be addressed there
because sometimes Ways and Means will
make adjustments to the amount so in the
prior B any and we initially budgeted 2
million that was increased to 3 million
um during that process and that then
that shows up as available Revenue that
would be reflected in the Surplus
statement as a benefit to the entire
state but yeah to clarify it's the state
it shows up in the state budget it
doesn't show up in the DHHS budget right
thank thank you for the
response okay so so two questions in
this regard um I I think I heard you say
that our our AG um may may be uh
relative to other states a little
underst staffed in in in this area area
um do we have a situation you think
where uh uh you guys are so good you're
you're creating a backlog at the AG and
the AG can't work through the workload
that you're handing them uh I wouldn't
want to speak for the AG's office um I'm
I'm you know we can certainly have that
conversation with them and and bring you
information well I don't get to talk to
the AG I I but but if if you're thinking
that there's a a problem there I can
talk to the division that handles it and
have them pay attention to it as they're
doing their budget presentation from our
perspective I don't think that we feel
like we're experiencing a backlog um but
they do have 50 cases
between how many people do you think
work there three three people three
attorneys yeah I don't know how many
attorneys they would need but um okay so
have you ever calculated kind of a
return on investment to where if we
hired an incremental person to pursue
fraud that we would expect X dollars
back
no do you think that's a p a possible
math problem when we do these reviews
we're not doing it necessarily for
volume of dollars we're doing it for the
behavior we're trying to stem any fraud
Behavior so it could be I mean many of
these cases are things like home health
or non-emergency medical transportation
these are not necessarily high
dollar
uh co services you know these are these
aren't services that we're paying lots
and lots of money to an individual for
but if someone is defrauding the
Medicaid Program we need to find the
behavior and stop the
behavior okay thank you go ahead for
just to follow your your question
representative Edwards um later today
Melissa Saint seir um who who is uh
representative of the or she's Chief
legal officer she will be talking about
the Medicaid estate recoveries unit um
which Falls within her team we have
looked at that and there are estate
recoveries that are available that we
are not collecting and we have looked at
the numbers of staff that would be
needed we can certainly talk about that
later when Melissa's here cuz there
there is revenue that's available that
would fall into that sort of
unrestricted Revenue category if it were
generated but currently that team
doesn't have the staff to um to capture
everything good looking forward to it
was there a
question thank you Mr
chairman on line
042 additional French benefits I know
this is what page are we on I'm sorry
we're on page
1046 at the bottom of the page okay got
got it thank you I'm just curious why
there was um funding for both
2024 and that there's just zero for the
remaining 26 and
27 so the additional French benefits
have been centralized uh in in AU uh
9500 um what we found was it was uh
fairly administratively burdensome um
the way that it was set up in the uh in
in the system today so we tried to
centralize that to make things a little
bit more efficient um to maximize our
operating capacity
frankly okay thank you so much so miss
tell us uh oh representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here I don't want it to go
unnotice just how much work and
information is in the budget briefing
book related to your Bureau on page 16
of that book I see State mandate
I see Federal mandates are those the
primary places for which fraud is
detected and violations would occur uh
yes I would say it's not those are not
all just related to fraud um they also
might be related to uh our third party
liability requirements for example
[Music]
um I'm not sure what that one is yeah or
or the general Integrity of the Medicaid
Program which also includes the
requirements behind provider enrollment
which is intended to prevent fraud from
occurring so that's the site visits and
screenings of
providers thank you for the question all
right it's it's noon I don't want to
pressure you because this is all good
work what how much time do you need to
feel like you can wrap up uh completely
do we want to aim for five minutes all
right you got five minutes okay you got
six okay so uh slide 10 is just a list
of federal Audits and reviews that took
place during 2024 that we helped to
facilitate slide 11 the Bureau of
program
quality Bureau of program quality
consists of five unique work units that
partner with DHHS programs to provide
datadriven support and evaluation for
program development program quality and
performance Improvement and those
functional work units are data analytics
and Reporting which is what it sounds
like uh the Medicaid quality program
which manages the quality strategy the
quality strategy federally required by
CMS quality strategy for our Managed
Care Program uh substance misuse
planning and evaluation which does that
kind of program development program
evaluation just specific to substance uh
use disorder uh services
our health services assessment unit uh
which creates and administers really
really rigorous reviews of providers for
quality and compliance and we do that
again on behalf of program areas or we
work with program areas to develop a
review tool that they can use on their
own and our contracts quality management
unit which creates all the tools for
contract management to be used by
program areas um and and actually we
work really closely with a lot of those
program areas for to give like technical
assistance on how to use those
tools slide 13 really just offers more
detailed description of some of the work
of the Bureau of program quality um just
to provide some
examples yeahor sorry excuse me go um on
on slide on page 11 I just a kind of a
curiosity question what is a sentinel
event I was just going to describe your
timing is perfect uh so a sentinel event
is a particular type of event sorry very
well defined in our policy uh really it
really falls into very particular
categories of some kind of critical
event that takes place with one of our
beneficiaries the providers serving that
beneficiary are required to report the
event to us uh to the to the program
area and the program area will do their
own review our role as a as a division
then is is to host a sentinel event
review where we take the information we
work with the external stakeholders and
we're we're doing a quality assurance
review to try to get to the root cause
of the event so so simply a is it true
that a sentinel event then is a is an
individual case of a patient that seems
to be uh exorbitant in terms of the
costs so we're looking we're looking at
the care and the costs not related to
the cost necessar no something happened
a person for example died or was
critically injured yeah that is
something people would be a provider
would be required to report to certain
providers would be required to report to
us and we would then work with them it
there is a case that's required to be
reported the program area will manage
the case and the response to the case
what we do is for example particularly
if we see trends like like more than one
instance happens with a certain providor
type or a certain case type we will call
together the program area external
stakeholders the providers and we will
say what is happening here that might be
C that caused this one event or this
series of events so that we can prevent
it from happening do you do you also
have uh like uh the ability with the
intelligence system or whatever systems
you're using to identify say the top 50
most expensive individual patients that
we have so that we can do an appropriate
case management agement review or or is
that all ad hoc and and and random how
we find out about
those so separating out the cost there
is actually now uh CMS requirements to
develop a system that can do exactly
what you are referring to so where we
are combining multiple reporting systems
so that we can see is something
happening to people multiple times and
Trend with different providers and
different types of people in different
cases uh so that is a system that we are
actually currently working on um do we
have any existing Capa capability that
helps us do that I mean I hear you that
you're going to develop it but I'm just
curious what we've been doing the last
couple of
years we we do we we do have
capabilities uh in our mismis system for
example to look at certain things um
what we're looking at is trying to pull
multiple systems together so that we can
have a full picture of cases and that's
the work that's being done now both in
our ebi system and uh with with our um
Bureau of uh adult and Aging Services as
well for the incidents that they're that
are reported to
them
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
um thank you for all the work that you
do it's excellent thank thank you um do
you have any cost effective measures
that you have
used to show the outside world
us um how much cost
savings you have done for the state like
how much millions of dollars you have
saved the state because you've gone back
to assure that there was adequacy of
services and not fraud going
on so the graphic on
slide six
no slide
nine represents overpayments that we've
recovered for example that doesn't
include fraud so I could get separate
numbers for fraud okay it also doesn't
include the waste and abuse captured by
the
mcos uh which would be a separate number
from that um and
I for example in third party
liability there is an amount related to
cost savings you said cost savings right
so what we call Cost avoid when Medicaid
is the payer of Last Resort another
insurer has already paid the bill when
we have properly functioning TPL systems
third party Li ability systems we aren't
getting the bill because somebody else
has already paid it we can't capture
that
data that's in the millions and millions
of dollars but but someone else has
received the claim so I don't have the
claim to tell you how much it's worth
but but in the big picture in uh isn't
it the case that what you're what you're
trying to do is really control or
improve and modify behaviors and if
you're successful in that
then the opportunity to collect is
actually reduced and so you you've got
kind of an IR an ironic situation in
that if the if our goal is to increase
collections it's almost like you have to
let the behavior run wild so you can
catch
more that's correct yes so our first
goal is what we the behaviors what we
refer to is internal controls so we are
always looking to improve our internal
controls our system of internal control
which is policies and procedures
documentation training communication
it's the really fundamental core of
management so that things are working
right in the first place beautiful yes I
understand that and I appreciate all of
this um again thank you if you could get
us those other numbers because that kind
of helps to
justify yeah you know why this is so
important we can certainly get that
thank you
okay did did you have um couple closing
statements uh slide 14 just to explain
what you're looking at
there it's a graphic rep no not 14 sorry
13 it's just a graphic representation of
our quality strategy so the Medicaid
quality priorities are up at the top for
our Managed Care uh program and the what
we refer to as our quality levers are on
the Le hand side here these are
different levers of incentives that we
use Financial incentives to the managed
care plans uh to to try to incent them
to produce quality performance in each
of these different
areas could I suggest you work with Mr
Williams uh to uh add this to HHS
oversight and you can come tell
oversight more about this because I
think this this just suggests a lot of
really good information I will have that
conversation with him yes all right yeah
thank you anything else no I think as we
mentioned our budget is almost entirely
Personnel um we have three unfunded
positions in each of the two bureaus and
that that's
it okay well thank thank you very much
uh if you if you want to uh tell us more
later or send us stuff we'd be I'd be
happy to see it great uh are there any
final questions from the committee no
okay so I think we're ready to recess
for lunch uh I think we uh it's 12:10 I
think we can still try to get back at 1
uh we're going to talk to Legal uh the I
guess that's bis business Information
Systems facilities and everyone's
favorite topic Health
Equity so um all right so with that
we're at recess until 1 o' thank you
I I learn more I learn
more
e
e e
one minute warning you're out in the
hall come on
in e
all right it's uh it's 1:00 uh we're
going to uh bring division three out of
recess um and uh we've got four
presentations to uh this afternoon
um I'm I'm thinking that we can probably
complete this in in two hours as my
initial goal um so uh all right and with
that introduce yourself and let's
go hi good morning or oh sorry good
afternoon Melissa Saint here I'm the
chief legal officer for the Department
of Health and Human
Services and Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services um in your uh
in your presentation book there the next
uh presentation should be the office of
legal and Regulatory Services the
PowerPoint should be there um this this
area has a few more accounting units
than than some of the other areas so I
think a good starting point would be to
turn to in the governor's operating
budget to turn to page
1,48 um to start this this area does
cover through through pages
1,54 I believe um so all all of those
accounting units within that within that
page range um would be included in this
presentation and in
the in the uh DHHS briefing book um this
begins on page
it's more towards the
end there it
is on page 17 is where this section will
begin so with that I will hand it over
to Melissa hello good afternoon again um
so we'll start with the Bureau of
Licensing and certification the Bureau
of Licensing and certification has two
components child care licensing and
health facilities licensing so child
care licensing licenses and inspects and
ensur safety and um Health regulations
are followed for child care
facilities that includes uh daycare
centers residential programs as well as
youth recreation camps um that occur
during the summer so we we do those
regulations um and they get annual
inspections and um licensing uh
application processes as well as we uh
address the criminal background checks
for all all childcare workers that work
in in child care facilities were
responsible for completing their um
criminal background
checks and then Health Care Facilities
um and certification there there are a
couple of different components licensing
for the State of New Hampshire so we uh
license we inspect we ensure that they
apply and that they are operating with a
license for all Healthcare facilities
and there's a myriad of healthcare
facilities hospitals nursing homes uh
Residential Care Facilities like
assisted livings we also do um adult
daycare centers ambulance Sur surgical
centers dialysis centers I mean the list
really goes on and on that uh if they
receive a federal funding as well so
there are some that just are licens and
just uh perform services within the
state and don't receive any federal
funding you'll see a lot of their
assisted livings are like that where
they just um receive either State
funding or they receive or or they're
paid privately basically to live there
those um will only get a state license
those that receive federal funding will
also get what's called a certification
and that team is also within the
department within that unit and they are
um basically take direction from CMS
from the regional office of CMS to
perform certification requirements to
ensure Federal Regulations are met as
well and then additional certification
also occurs for our community residences
so those Community residences per
perform services and care for
individuals with developmental
disabilities they're generally like
homik environments where people live so
they're certified to receive state
funding um through our Bureau of
Developmental Disabilities um and then
they also receive a license if there are
a larger faciliity so four or more um
individuals who live in a facility then
they would also get a state license to
ensure that there's a lot more oversight
around kind of the building not just the
health and safety of the care that's
being provided but also ensure that the
building is safe there's fire codes are
being met and all of those type of
things so so there are different
components for the Bureau of Licensing
and certification and depending on the
services that are provided that's
essentially what um each of them
do thanks if I may sure
please finish your introduction I have
finished for Bureau of Licensing and
certification okay uh questions so the
question so are on the I understand the
State Licensing piece of it are you
doing the certification for the federal
correct yes we are and you're
compensated for that yes we are uh
generally most of our the staff are
almost they're the majority of the
funding for their positions are federal
or federal funds for those positions and
so when you do that you're doing the
certification and the licensing at the
same time so we actually have a deemed
license status in the state of New
Hampshire so if somebody is in
compliance with the certification the
federal certification requirements which
are a little bit more stringent than our
state laws then they get a license
through the state of New Hampshire so we
actually don't do two inspections we
just do the one okay thank
you representative
priest thank you and and thank you for
providing us a chart with the Staffing
for each of these three areas on page
two uh on page four um can you tell us
how many uh Child Care um facilities or
programs
you um you review and certainly yeah so
actually it's on page 13 oh my goodness
okay yeah I know it's at the it's at the
end so all of our case load and kind of
data around the numbers are um on those
pages so on page 13 you'll see childcare
licensing we inspect 712 family and
center-based licensed daycare centers we
have 24 residential programs and 19
license exempt and those license exempt
are basically they don't qualify to get
a state license they don't need to
because they just have a small number of
kids maybe two kids that they care for
but they are receiving funding from our
ccdf um federal
funds for kids that maybe um need that
need that funding to assist with their
child care so um we we inspect those as
well so uh there that covers 46,700
childcare slots um and this also gives
you the number of uh recreational camps
which is 159 and we have 363 complaints
that we handled this past
year okay thank you very much of course
what what's what what's kind of a a
general nature of a of the complaints
you handle I I know that there's a range
but what's sort of a typical one that
you seem to get a lot of um you know I
don't know if there is a typical you you
know it's really around um sometimes you
know they don't seem to have enough stat
or they the staff that aren't allowing
them to go the kids to go outside or um
you know we've noticed some things that
are unclean and you know it really can
be a wide range um of of complaints so
it's hard to say I don't I can certainly
go back and see if they have any data
though that we can provide you no I'm
just kind of conversational get my head
around it a little bit sure um and then
well for those kind of complaints which
sound fairly General
are are there are there almost always
some sort of Regulation that you were
enforc you're inspecting against a a
requirement and a
regulation yes absolutely we would
always I mean if if we receive a
complaint and it's something that's
regulated we would look at the
regulation and then we would do an
inspection if it was something that's
you know um my daycare center does not
provide lunch and I would really love
for them to provide lunch you know
that's not a requirement under the
regulations that's a choice that the
business would make so um that's
something we wouldn't then inspect we
would screen that out and then there are
federal regulations because I'm I'm just
sort of curious why we get so much
Federal money for child care licensing
yeah so our child care development block
grant um does provide for children to
receive child care in um different
incomes our child development Bureau
provides that funding um so they're
actually part of um a different Bureau
so we're not responsible we just handle
the regulatory side of things but they
do provide funding they provide funding
some for our technology to they provide
funding for our criminal background
checks to make sure those are complete
so there's some funding that streams in
related to that so so Mr White that that
that money isn't showing up twice is it
it's not showing up as a grant in one
department and then it's showing up is
revenue for for for child care licensing
it no we it certainly should should not
be they'll be double budgeting it and we
we can't do that yeah
okay good one one quick one so no no no
representative
priest thank you um on your community
residences where does that appear within
the governor's budget what page
number so there's Child Care license
this
here2 okay it's on page 1052 I've got it
okay thank you very much representative
Al real real quick one do you charge a
licensing fee to anybody and where does
that show yeah so RSA 151 um is for
health facilities there's a there's a
specific charge it's in statute of what
we charge sometimes like hospitals it's
per bed other facilities it's per
facility um depending so that's actually
in the statute um and then child care
licensing uh there is no fee for to
become a a licensed child care
provider and where does that the revenue
piece of it shows shows
where I I I don't I don't see that
revenue
for
5143 either
I will have to get back to you just to
verify the where the revenue is coming
in but I I will do that would would
would it be the objective to to match
the revenue to the the expense Center or
or would you just sweep it under a
general account
somewhere I I I I I I need to look into
the details just to verify the revenue
Source I don't misspeak okay uh
representative PRI
oh
okay uh
what okay
uh so so you think uh line
009 on page
1048 where it says agency income in 25
where it says
35,600 you think that may be a licensing
fee
I I I I believe and and again I I I
don't really want to verify talk about
this until we verify but I believe it's
in 5146
07 07 the agency income at the
bottom but but but again I I'd like to
take that back and verify it okay
because that's summarized under Health
Facilities admin but okay that's why I'd
like to take it back all right super are
there other questions on the on the
licensing I see you've got n 19 people
is that the right number you got 19
people in child care licensing what
what's your vacancy
rate um I believe we
have is it two positions
you don't have it yeah we we don't have
it at that level of detail we can
certainly get that there was one
unfunded position in childcare licensing
and accounting unit 5143 though okay one
unfunded and I don't expect there to be
a substantial job description
requirements for these
19 that that they don't have a criminal
record that they're able to communicate
effectively I you don't have like a
degree
requirement um I would have to go back
to their job description I believe that
um a majority of our folks do have an
early childhood de uh development kind
of degree so I would have to go back to
see if that's just the nature of the job
or if they act if it's a requirement on
the job description okay I'd appreciate
that distinction um and then I don't see
any other questions you want to
entertain so similar question on page
1050 under positions you got 32
positions there are do you know if any
of those have been
unfunded yeah there was um some that
were unfunded for our certification
team I don't know you I think it was um
ju just to clarify you indicated page
1050 this is for the accounting unit
5146 yeah I moved over to health
facilities am I not on Health Facilities
by
right yeah yeah so so there's five
unfunded positions in accounting unit
okay now I see I see big numbers here in
the um case
loads um do you have a a backlog
currently or or what what's your general
response time when you get a fresh
complaint so it depends on um typically
we go out within 24 to 48 hours if it's
something that we believe is a risk to
health and safety um it would be almost
immediately um if it's something that's
a little less uh you know of a risk
essentially it could be you know those
48 hours to potentially a week are there
are regulations through CMS that our
teams have to go in at their Direction
so there are times where CMS says no you
need to go in today and so we'd have to
follow that for our certification team
but the licensing team has a little bit
more flexibility generally we're we're
out there very very quickly we don't we
don't let things sit so we do not have a
backlog and and if if um if if somebody
has a CFI and they're staying at their
own home there's no requirement to
inspect their own that home right
correct we don't we do not inspect their
homes what what's what's the smallest
unit of care that you do end up
inspecting
um I don't know we don't NE neily go by
that we go by The Entity we license The
Entity so if if a home health agency is
responsible for providing uh home health
care for individuals we will inspect the
agency we will ensure we'll look at
their medical records we'll take samples
of those we'll we'll you know obviously
take complaints and and inspect them but
we wouldn't go into somebody's physical
home um but we may reach out to an
individual who's receiving that care to
see if there's any concerns related to
the care so um it would really all be
around the entity and not the individual
that's receiving the care okay and and
and although a home health agency
doesn't necessarily have a facility
because it goes out to support you would
still inspect the agency even though
you're not inspecting a facility correct
we would make sure that their
information is secure that people's
privacy is being considered um you know
so we do actually look at those those
agencies practices all right Senor yes
pleas thank you for taking questions
sure um I assume and if I'm wrong foster
care is outside of the perview of what
you do correct foster care is licensed
under
dcyf representative
priest thank you Mr chairman
um again back to community
residences so what I'm hearing is that
you don't
certify group homes up to five
individuals we certify everyone so even
if a facility if a if a home has even
one individual in it we still certify
them do you me do you monitor them so
there's no absolutely we do yep
inspections and they get a certification
the only time they get a license um
which is is when they have bigger
facilities so they required to have
certification and a license when you say
bigger facilities what four or more four
or more four or more but either way
they're getting they're getting a full
inspection related to the certification
requirements okay thank
you okay I I don't think I I have a
question that there's no answer for
which is uh what What's the average
length of time to do an inspection I
guess it just would be facility
variable how how long it takes us to do
an inspection yeah very very facility
variable um however you know very small
facilities also um we may be at an say
an assisted living if it's a large
Assisted Living we could be there for a
week and if it's a small Assisted Living
just a few days depending on on the size
okay all right I I don't see any other
questions on this do you want to go to
the next sure absolutely uh so our next
is our Bureau for Legal Services um
there's lots of uh things that fall
under that Bureau general
counsel is uh our is basically our group
of attorneys and uh other legal
professionals who perform services to
the entire department legal services to
the entire department so they could be
uh in they could be reviewing laws and
rules and giving um legal advice on the
interpretation of things they also could
be um attending hearings that on behalf
of the state for services that that were
were not provided um they may represent
the department in court they may
represent the department in an
administrative hearing um um you know
guardianships all of those type of
things so our general Council does do a
lot of um internal external audits
they're responding obviously to lawsuits
Federal compliance um developing
policies um obviously interpretations
investigating things so uh I don't I
mean there's there's a lot of work they
cover the entire department the Bureau
of general counsel has somebody so we
have like one attorney that represents
Medicaid we have one attorney that
represents our long-term supports and
services so that's generally what our
general Council does so so I'm looking
at page 151 uh for the Governor's budget
in 26 I see a total of 100 positions is
that for this legal council office so
that includes our child support
attorneys and all of our DC wife
attorneys as
well and and um two two things i' just
like to point out in in the accounting
unit 560
5680 um first there's there's 13
unfunded positions in total there's
there's um two classified and 11
unclassified and one thing that will
certainly catch your eye is you will see
a pretty steep decrease in funding in
the class 10 Personnel line and a pretty
uh steep increase in the class 12 line
um during the last budget uh chapter 79
section 218 laws of
2023 we the um um there was a provision
of law in in House Bill 2 that converted
the classified attorneys to
unclassified and so that's also at the
bottom why you'll see that change in in
numbering as far as unclassified
positions versus classified and and that
speaks to most of that on top of that
again we had 13 unfunded in this uh
current uh stage of the
budget did I did I hear you say you're
involved in law suits I I thought once
the lawsuit was filed uh the AG handled
it and and you consult it so the AG does
take over and represent the department
in um when the department is sued
specifically for for
issues they we do have to perform as you
can imagine an enormous amount of
Discovery for those so we do have
attorneys that handle those Discovery
requests we also um a lot of times are
served and have to start the process for
the lawsuit and then send it over to the
doj and then we're involved in strategy
sessions and other things um you know
that that would relate to the lawsuit so
so that reminds me of a question I asked
two or four years ago um have has has
the state or
DHHS obtained an eisc Discovery system
to help you with Discovery or are you
still doing it the oldfashioned way so
we do have um we have a couple of um
programs that do assist with uh
Discovery but we haven't although we
have them available we have not kicked
them off fully and I think Dave weers
who's here in the audience could
probably talk a little bit more about um
where we are in the integration of of
that of those programs so I would assume
if you had the eisc discovery systems
working that that would save a
tremendous amount of Manpower it C it
can yeah absolutely but we have to I
mean as you can imagine some of these
lawsuits you know spend years and so
getting all of that data yeah yeah yeah
where where do you keep your offline
records are they in some building here
in New Hampshire or so our paper records
um a lot of them are kept in our
archives um in the archives and we we
retrieve them from archives it's not a
lime cave is it by any
chance uh yeah yeah and then there's
others we we keep stored at at in the
buildings in which we occupy so are we
are we aging out to where our um record
retention period is being reached and we
can retire more and more paper records
or do you have some obligation to keep a
record for 40 or 50 years or life of a
patient or something yeah so it depends
it really does um you know DCF has you
know 30 Years or or however longer um
you know a lot of them have all
different time periods we're actually
that's one of our projects on the road
map is that we're um Gathering all of
that information and ensuring that the
time periods where we are to keep data
and then we're able to purge the data
that that shouldn't be kept um to ensure
privacy so we're doing all of that leg
work right now that's actually an
initiative that's that we're working on
so if I were to find the commissioner's
road map you're you're you're a square
somewhere in there to the data retention
work absolutely yep it's uh commitment
three initiative
four yeah I got it
right okay are there uh yes represent
torki thank you thank you for taking my
question I jumped ahead a couple pages
to page 15 to the list of active
litigation and um looking at in
particular the first two bullet points
and the sheer number of um cases and
pending cases and then going back to the
statement that you have 13 unfunded
positions so I'm just curious about how
your department there can manage um is
everything being addressed in a timely
manner that there is not damage being
done to one party or the other yes I I
say I would say that we definitely have
an ability to manage that at the onset
of all the claims that were processed
for the YDC litigation it wasn't um we
didn't have our ducks in a row at that
point it did take a little bit longer to
kind of understand the volume and try to
get all the documents there are people
in basements ensuring that we were
gathering as much information as we
possibly could we have a very good
system in place now and it took us a
little time but we definitely have a
system in place now and we're able to
respond very timely thank you
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman um
going back
to
um going back to uh page
1050 of 01 I mean 010
012 you you mentioned there was some
regulation that caused staff to be
disass ified and others explain that to
me again please and when did that happen
wasn't that just a legislative act to
move people from class to unclass or
vice yeah that's exactly it so um
working with the legislature uh in 2023
there was a mandate for the Department
to move all of the DCF attorneys to from
classified positions to unclassified
positions and then as of June 30th of
2025 this year abolish the classified
positions once we were able to move
everyone over so you're going to see
that in the budget how that that change
so they're the same amount of staff the
same or at least without the unfunded
positions not considering those the
Mandate was same amount of staff same
positions they're just moving from
classified to unclassified and the
reason for this was just because of the
work required to address this correct as
I remember the legislative debate
unclass is a salaried position and
classified as a hourly position yeah and
so I think it was uh one to
professionalize uh the the staff and to
also maybe uh save some money on
overtime okay all makes sense not that
we would ever do that because we worry
about the quality of the litigation
right thank
you so uh as as identified already child
support our child support Council our
child support um Bureau and the DCF
Council they are in our budget DCF
council do actually report up from a um
you know from a job perspective from
kind of the tasks and the roles of those
positions they report to the Attorney
General's office but they are in our
budget so um they dictate their their
work but we we manage their them from an
administrative perspective so that's why
you see d2f Council
here so for that to make sense from a
budgeting perspective the department
should still exercise a significant
amount of control over the the work
products even though they report to the
AG we work very closely together as you
can imagine and um yes I absolutely
think that we have a great working
relationship and a partnership to ensure
that people are um being taken care of
and that they are able to do their job
but that we also are being fiscally
responsible but it's more than a
caretaker role it's a it's a leadership
super advisory uh quality of work
relationship between the department
Absol absolutely uh if de Baker were
here she's the um she's the person in
charge she is the head of DCF Council
she would tell you that the exact thing
we we definitely work together super uh
did we skip Ombudsman or haven't gotten
there yet all right yeah um the next
thing I had was legislative Services we
have um director of uh legislation John
Williams who many of you probably
already know and have met um and then
our legislative Leons we have uh an
enormous amount of legislative lons
they're those are folks they're not um
Standalone these are all of the
attorneys that have been that are part
of our general Council they perform
legislative Services as well so um
that's one of their roles within their
job and we just wanted to point that out
because you do see a lot of our general
counsel staff coming through um to
represent the department on different
things but they are they are not their
own um it's not their own uh you know
position it is not just legislative lons
we actually have they are doing that
work as general members of general
counsel so so what what class line are
you on what four
digit they would fall in um in yeah in
general Council so um um page 1051 1051
it it's accounting unit 5680 or 5680 568
5680 the the the general Council which
begins on 1050 and continues on 1051 um
and and to to Melissa's point the
legislative Le Liaisons those there's a
number of positions that sit in other
bureaus and acting as a legislative
leison is only one of their job
responsibilities um they also do many
other things within their respective
areas as well but it's it's more of a
organizational this is the only way we
could address the hundreds of bills
affecting DHHS each year to track it
right do you ever throw Mr Williams a
case just to make sure he can still Loy
I think he does a lot of that
already okay all right um the next uh
I'm on page 11 on this on the um
PowerPoint is our administrative Appeals
Unit our administrative Appeals Unit ma
uh manages our adjudicative process
that's that exists in statute
um under RSA
541a it is IT addresses any area and it
and accepts appeals for any area in
which somebody could appeal so if they
are denied benefits or Services they
would appeal through the administrative
Appeals Unit um we have five
administrative law judges and three
clerical folks who take those and
address those um issues on the
PowerPoint you can see some of um some
of the examples of some of the cases
that we take
um those are most common but
certainly uh you know there's a there's
a broad range of things that they that
they hear and we handle a little over a
thousand cases where we actually hear a
case a little over a thousand of them
throughout the year but as you can
imagine we get a lot of appeal requests
and um some of them aren't appealable
issues and so we have to manage those as
well so so administrative appeals looks
like it's its own brand branch on the
wire diagram what what what uh
four-digit code or is that under also in
general counsil it's no it's 563 okay
that's the
5683 83 Y and what page is that
1052 and 1051 n 1051 yeah
y operation support Administration yes
is the administrative Appeals that
is okay and so that's staying constant
at eight are there any unfunded
positions in there no um so so so there
are no unfunded positions in there and
uh there was a type of technically in
the governor's budget there are six
positions in that in that accounting
unit okay so where it says eight that's
meant to be six yes
and so was it eight in the current year
so there's a decline of two apologize
eight is correct number I was reading on
the wrong page no that's all right I I
made a mistake once it's okay and and uh
also operation support admin
um has no unfunded positions that I'm
seeing right now how how's your vacancy
rate we're full you're
full okay
so our next two on page 12 is are the
two EMB budsman offices that exist at uh
at the department the first is our
general EMB budman's office that General
EMB budman's office is handles all
complaints throughout for any services
that the department provides so so I got
to crosswalk the the budget briefing
with where you're at also the the hb1
what pages are we on so if you turn to
page
1053 accounting unit
5696 um
budsman got it and I will also talk
about the long-term care emment which is
6636 accounting
unit okay and then in the budget book
1054 no I mean this 33 page staple
document the en criptions I don't think
either of them are in there um so the um
budsman is not included in there because
it is under $1 million and the long-term
care un budsman is also not included
because it's also under a million
dollars which is the threshold that we
use for the accting units in the budget
briefing book all right thank you uh so
the other than the DHHS un budman which
handles all complaints um they
confidential complaints they address uh
issues and they they make a
determination
they kind of look at the issue and make
a determination as to whether or not
they believe the department did
something that they shouldn't have done
and then they'll work with the
Department to make sure it's it's in
line with with what our rules and
regulations are or or they'll um or
they'll uh try to attempt to help the
individual even if even if we have
followed our regulations to try to
attempt to resolve their issue so the
EMB budsman office is is there to help
all clients all issues across the entire
department the office of long-term care
and budsman is spefic specifically just
for those who reside in long-term care
facilities they're administratively
attached to the department they're they
go into long-term care facilities to
assist in um and be advocates for the
residents in any kind of concern or
issue that they have um while residing
in that long-term care facility so
that's the difference between those two
offices okay
6633 6636
you got five
there is it and what's their story are
they you have vacancies you have any
unfunded positions neither no vacancies
no unfunded all right representative
yeah very quick very quick question back
on uh page 1050 where it shows no no no
wrong page 1051 two lines that show
agency income what what uh what's the
source of of the income there is that
recovery on litigation or so the 009
line um what that
represents this goes back to the budget
um the budget system that we were
talking about earlier today um in in
state fiscal year 24 at the end of the
year we brought forward an item to
fiscal to allocate other funds across
the department and that that was um
approved and that's why you're seeing
the actual expense show up there 25 is
zero because this was pre-budget system
and the cost that you see in state
fiscal year 26 and 27 those are
allocated costs from other funds from
other areas of the department to make it
clear and and represent the cost that
this team incurs and supporting New
Hampshire hospital and Glen Cliff home
and the other areas the and that's the
009 agency income the
007 is the uh some of the estate
recovery funds uh that this that um
the department is able to recover by the
Medicaid Program so just as a followup
that's a a cost sharing or a cost
allocation and stuff that comes from
other other departments it's it's other
revenue generated by other departments
that's being attributed to the revenue
here to cover the expenses that are
incurred in supporting those
areas okay thank you representative
Stringham so I'm looking at this you
have 1,600 uh cases through the
ombudsman's office so there's staff of
four so that's basically two new cases
per person day is that a reasonable
amount for somebody to be able to
clear uh given the kind of split of
cases that would be part of that 1600
cases um I mean obviously they'd always
love to have some more staff to handle
some of those cases I think that they're
really skilled in um being able to
connect them to the right people um a
lot of times they people call to say
that you know I'm not getting I don't
know who to contact I'm not sure who you
know and and they're really good at
ensuring that they they get them
connected so I think that um you know
that's part of it obviously being part
of the department is really helpful for
working together um another thing that
they were able to do these last couple
of years is identify areas in which they
um that the department they've seen they
may have seen some Trends and they've
been able to say well I've we've gotten
a lot of calls about this one issue like
let's fix this one issue and that's what
we've we've really attempted to try to
do over the last couple of years so even
though um you may see that the case
numbers are high and they certainly are
handling a lot of cases right now they
they are really skilled and doing the
work that they're doing and um and so
you know we we have had some mandates
through legislature or con um
conversations at least to try to get
individuals in the UDS men's office that
are specifically trained to deal with
certain different from populations
within the state um so we may see some
movement there and that would be really
helpful for for the for the EMB
bussman's office I mean I don't want to
say that we have all the people that we
need because we definitely could use
more but I will say that they do a
really good job with what they have well
if they specialize and there's only four
of them and they have to cover the
entire State geographically and it looks
like uh pretty high percentage of cases
involve the site visit um so the EMB
busman's office doesn't is is n required
to do any site visits um so they they
usually handle most of their stuff I
mean certainly they will meet with with
clients if necessary but they do a lot
of their work
remotely I would imagine that there's
some uh conceptual Pi chart for this
1600 that shows a significant number of
them is is represents a referral to the
right person to follow up on without
spending a great deal of time in the um
bu
yeah defin definitely um you know and it
is just connecting sometimes it's just
connecting them to the right people
smaller piece of the pie chart would be
a serious investigation right them doing
a full investigation that is yeah that's
a smaller percentage yeah thank you I I
have another question the um uh and I
want to zoom out a little bit and that
is you know what we're looking at here
all the expenses are largely personnel
and cost driven by Personnel like
benefits and so on in these charts if um
where would it show up if there are
related to these Services you know say
you say in this area you you contract
with 100 uh pis to do investigation
they're contracted they're not
um uh uh not I don't think they're part
in in here so I I just in zooming out
I'm thinking you know what can what can
we recommend either from moving contract
workout into your department through
staff or the other way around and right
now I feel like we're seeing the staff
part of it and not maybe uh other pieces
of critical expenditures that you
require to do your function that you you
know you may be able to trade off on so
maybe that's a question for Nathan it's
you know because I think it involves
everything we've looked at today not
just this so yeah we don't have the the
the office of legal and Regulatory
Services has very very few contracts um
so I think what you're talking about may
be related more to other bureaus that do
investigations you know we have Adult
Protective Services that will
investigate individuals for abuse and
neglect um for adults uh those
individuals are employed as well so we
don't really have we have we really
don't have very many contracts at all um
in our Bureau it is mostly staff and it
it is mostly although like the EMB
budsman is outward facing our general
Council folks which which we actually
just have a few of them um are are
internal and really support internal
programs so um I certainly can think
about it and take it back and and um and
and talk to folks a little bit more to
see if there's anything that we can do
to streamline um but we don't have any
existing contracts right now as in in
the way that you're suggesting yeah
I want to ask you my it question what
what's what's the core it um support
system for utsman do are you using
sales.com
Okay y representative
priest thank you Mr chairman uh back to
page uh 13 again on your handout y um
again the four staff that you have
identified in the budget do they all
also do the uh long-term care outb so
the there's four staff for the EMB
budsman office and then there's another
for the long-term care EMB buzzman
office and how many staff they have four
as well four as well
okay a few years ago the legislature
wanted the department to have
specifically a privacy officer and one
of the functions of the privacy officer
was to do privacy impact assessments has
that been implemented do we have that
position filled so we do have a privacy
well we did that's different we did have
a we have a privacy officer a hippoc
compliance privacy officer which is
required for us to be covered entity but
as for the impact sounds like Nathan so
so there there I I don't remember um the
bill number uh chairman words but that
bill was incorporated into hb2 and I
believe there were two positions
established within the Bureau of
Information Services for those privacy
impact assessments that you're referring
to and and I believe those have been
budgeted okay because in my experience
the P the Privacy officers tended to
hand hang out in the legal area and not
and not as much in the it area we we do
have I mean being a covered entity a hip
a covered entity we have to have a
privacy officer so that person does sit
within the department for under my
purview so they are within legal okay um
but it but that's a little bit different
than the and I'm I know Dave is sitting
in the back he might be able to answer
this better so just an editorial note
for you to take away and that is that
one of the reasons we established a a
privacy officer position was because it
was in the aftermath of the
2018 uh constitutional amendment to
protect privacy of New Hampshire
citizens and at the time there was a
perception that the department wasn't
particularly good at having a culture of
privacy protection so we wanted to get
somebody in there who would educate the
leadership on a culture of privacy and
I'm I'm still concerned that when you
talk to leadership in the department
they uh don't respect as a rule um the
requirement to have all data collection
be done on an opt-in basis and they
default to a government opt out approach
preferred approach and I think we have
to flip that have have you have you
looked or have you are you aware of any
internal consultation on when we're
going to end opt out and move to an
optin policy so that that's I think that
we we handle a lot of data so your the
opt-in versus opt out is different
depending on the data but I I'd love to
invite Dave weers to I don't know if you
want to take the seat over there Dave he
can talk a little bit more about that CU
he's definitely been involved from an IT
perspective okay so so I'm talking
specifically about known data
collections where we're Gathering
personal data and rather than ask the
individual to opt in we defer a default
to an opt out approach of data
collection um thank you for the question
again for the record Dave weers Chief
Operating Officer so so when it comes to
data that we're collecting directly we
have changed our our modus operandi of
doing opt-in consent-based
Gathering however lots of our
information that we do receive is not
through a program or service that we
offer so any state mandated or federally
mandated data would not necessarily
follow an opt-in process because I'm
still seeing surveys that go to
individuals that uh default to opt
out I'm be interested in hearing about
those we I would say that you're
absolutely correct there are still um
information that is out there that would
be an opt out function and but we are
going through the department with new
systems and new processes to identify a
standard consent-based approach um using
the DocuSign solution that you heard ear
earlier this morning so would you say
it's generally the policy of the
department to be migrating individual
data collection surveys and the like to
an optin approach for data collection we
have not made a policy for it but it is
general
practice okay so you have a privacy
governance board has this not been an
issue in the Privacy governance board on
what the policy of the department ought
to be so that's a a good point we do
have a privacy board as you indicated
and our David governance committee is
currently in draft mode for a data
policy for how we collect and manage
data including the Privacy impact
assessments and the management of optin
versus opt out there are numerous
programs across the department that may
or may not benefit from an optin or opt
out so it would be a case-by case basis
um and then I don't know if you want an
answer to the Privacy impact assessment
uh question it doesn't sound like you've
implemented it yet but you intend
to that is correct we we do intend to um
for the Privacy impact assessment
specifically we are on track to have a a
report that we will use as a standard
template using a technology called one
trust and that will be in place for
March and when do you think you'll have
privacy impact assessments routinely for
the implementation of new data
collection systems um in compliance with
the RSA we will have that in place in
March of this year March 2025
outstanding
thank you is there anything in the
department you don't know because you
seem to be a jack of all trades there is
a lot in the department I do not know
thank you all right so so I'm sorry
that's that's a that's a pet rock of
mine I I apologize so yeah so the only
other thing that I was going to mention
is what came up earlier was our estate
recoveries unit uh estate recoveries uh
recovers funds that were paid by the
state of New Hampshire um and by the
federal government for
services through our Medicaid um folks
so or our Medicaid members so if a
individual was uh able to say keep their
home and um they they were only able to
keep their home and live in it but they
needed Medicaid they needed a place to
live and they needed Medicaid to cover
their services we would allow them we
allow them to keep their home and um and
obviously still be covered under
Medicaid but to keep their home they
have to then um usually get a lean on
their on their house for the portions of
funds that have been expended by the
state so our estate recoveries recovers
those um those funds after uh through
Court
proceedings and right now we earn about
$7 million for it's not just for the
State of New Hampshire that's split up
between Federal funding County funding
and state funding um if we were to have
additional staff we believe that we
could increase that by $2
million um generally so that's uh we do
have money that's kind of left on the
table right now because we just don't
have the staff to be able to handle all
of the potential estate recoveries that
are out there what what what do you
think the estimated Personnel cost would
be in order to chase that 2 million
effectively we would need one one
attorney and two support staff so about
600,000 Personnel or less
so so just a couple of clarifying points
um the the general funds for State
fiscal year 26 that would' be needed
would be about 163,000 there' be
matching federal dollars available so
the total Personnel appropriation for
year one would be 258,000 however I
don't think you would need to budget
that much because we would need time to
create the positions and eventually hire
hire the individuals so probably about
half that it's about 270,000 total funds
in the second year and while we'd be
able to recover about $2 million uh 50%
of that would go back to the feds um we
would see about
$300,000 estimated go back to the
counties and then approximately
$700,000 would come to the state so if
those positions were funded by the state
fiscal year 27 the you know the the net
benefit would be in the range of $400 to
$500,000 again this is an estimate but
it would require about 3 FTE and it
could be more it could be less okay
that's great did did you just discuss
this in the agency phase with the
governor's office yes we did and and
what did what's was the conclusion it's
not anywhere in the budget is it a
prioritized need or is it nowhere uh
during during the agency phase and the
governor's phase we did not uh increase
um generally speaking the number of
positions across our our department and
so um I I think they're is concern
around increasing your number of
full-time authorized position despite
the revenue benefit
okay so so this is what I'd be open to
doing if if there were a small little
onepage business case that would explain
you know the the the Manpower side of it
the the expected costs the expected I'm
going to call it return on investment
even though we're government but I
that's the that's the business thought
so if you if you worked on something
like that and got it with Kevin I'd love
to uh consider that as part of what
we're doing then over the next month
sure well do
okay um uh are there do you have more
for us I don't I think that's are there
questions from the
committee yes representative
priest yes thank you very much uh and
again going with the
questions that uh representative Edwards
has mentioned um this could be an
expanding area given the Aging of New
Hampshire and the fact that we don't
have any long affordable long-term day
uh care facilities for those people and
they will have to care within their
houses
so um just an observation you're
referring to the Ombudsman area no I'm
talking about the attorneys that will go
after um the leans on the private
residences to recover the cost of
Medicare of to the state and federal
government that's amazing okay thank
you so so to flip that into another type
of question has the department done any
long-term trends analysis to figure out
what the increasing workload might be
from an aging population and the need to
do
more no we haven't done we haven't
estimated to the to the upcoming kind of
what we expect you know we have right we
have we have obviously all of the
trending that you know we have all the
data from the previous years but nothing
around the future thank you
representative Stringham I I wanted to
um uh ask ask you to expand a little bit
on and on your statements on wages and
key challenges the office is struggling
to recruit and maintain staff due to low
wages in a competitive environment uh
positions remain vacant for long periods
of time leading to burnout of current
staff and higher turnover is there
anything in this budget that addresses
those uh those concerns or is there
significant uh pay increases for example
for the could you help us understand
what page you're reading from that's a
Fage 16 page
16 of the handout the key challenges
this is a very very good section all
three all three bullet items in here um
in terms of um pointing an arrow for us
to potentially what to think about so
yeah anyway do you do you understand the
question I I do I I would say that we
don't I mean our budget
estimates you know what what we
currently spend with potential you know
Merit increases and those type of things
but there's no adjustment um to the
actual wages and and the wage scales
that are that apply to the positions I
think our biggest challenges
certainly our dcyf and child support
attorneys they have they are not
compensated in the way that they would
need to be to to they they hold High
case loads they have um very sensitive
information they have to be a lot of
times at court running around and doing
a lot of really great work those two
areas we struggle with recruitment um we
struggle with Recruitment and Retention
of those areas because they're very high
need high impact work um and it's it's
difficult to kind of maintain that level
and not have the financial compensation
I think the other area is in our Bureau
of Licensing and certification um
they're all especially our health
facilities they're all clinicians you
know so getting actual experienced
clinicians to be able to inspect our
health facilities for compliance health
and safety you know they have to have a
lot of experience to be able to to
identify concerns and issues so so we
definitely are seeing um those areas as
well strugg with the recruitment um
because they because we do need those
who have significant experience to be
able to ensure that others are providing
the services that they should provide so
uh you know reading this you know my U
interpretation or reading between the
lines is if you don't make adjustment in
in salaries in these areas you can
expect larger vacancies and uh di uh
diminished quality of services that's
being provided under this function yeah
I would say that the individuals that
that come to the department are very
dedicated and the quality that they want
to turn out is always of the highest
quality they are very I mean there's a
there's a mission within the work that
they're doing um you know that caring
for children and ensuring that people
are getting the services that they need
in in our health care facilities um
Child Care Facilities is really it's
really impressive the work that they do
so I would say that the quality for the
work that's being done will continue
because of the dedication of those
individuals I will say that we will
continue to have burnout and um and
difficulty in recruiting individuals
because of the the high needs and and um
expectations of those positions is there
a distinction between the classified and
unclassified positions are you talking
about the new the DCF ones I'm I'm
saying the the problem that we're
discussing is there a distinction in the
problem based on whether we're talking
class classified employees or
unclassified are these you're saying
wages typ typically that's a that's for
classified positions it would be salary
if we were talking about the the um the
unclassified yeah so a majority of the
staff that I have are classified staff
um even our attorneys the child's SP
attorneys for the longest time the DCF
attorneys were also classified it was
the just the most recent change where
they're going to unclassified um and and
and because we're just transitioning
them now it's hard to say what impact
that's going to have um on on those
those positions specifically but the
majority of them are classified thank
you uh representative Daniels thank you
with the worker shortage that we have in
the state do you see any areas in the
child care licensing that might be uh
relaxed or deregulated in maintaining
the safety
um are you asking if our staff if or the
staff that that operate at the child
care facility the CH
the the facilities that operate as child
care facilities I'm I'm wondering if
there are areas that uh may be over
regulated are there areas that can be
relaxed to allow uh a little more
flexibility W within child care so that
we can expand the child care and help
out the worker shortage
yeah absolutely so what we did um in for
our regulations for childcare licensing
is we did a campaign over the last year
to work with um a work group of child
care providers and uh address those any
kind of regulatory barriers or issues
that they may see and we actually began
to draft and write and make adjustments
to our regulations to address exactly
what you're talking about so th those
are we're in constant contact and
communication and we're in that that we
are um you know considering the
workforce shortage when when we're
drafting regulations we do have the
ability to have waivers and other things
but we have worked very closely with
them to make sure that there aren't
regulations that exist that are overly
burdensome any other questions um you
got a summary statement for us or or do
you think he covered everything I think
I covered everything all right well
thank you thank you very much thank you
I think we've got Bureau of Information
Systems up next so so we spent an an
hour on legal which was a great hour
um how much time if now some of the
Bureau of Information Systems this is
stuff that we picked up before the
budget got released so I'd really like
to have us focus more on the on the
resources needed and and and how that
money will be put to work man money and
Manpower
without going back over all the great
things the department does thank you
representative Edwards and committee uh
I am Ernie Gillan go I'm the director
for Information Services yeah this is
the first time you've been here it you
don't look familiar are you new or you I
I was the deputy director since 2019
under David weeders oh so he's been
hiding you he he has been I've been in
the back row uh and only at the table a
couple time so all right well thank you
and just to orient the committee um so
it the presentation should be the next
subsequent presentation in your in your
books there y the governor's operating
budget if you turn to page
1,60 again in the governor's operating
budget it's 1,60 and it's accounting
unit
5952 office of Information
Services and in the DHHS budget briefing
book its page it begins on page 27 at
the
bottom
okay ready when you
are so taking the um the clues
representative Edwards I'll move quickly
through these slides I know that a lot
of work was done by David in the pre
sessions coming here yeah but it doesn't
mean that don't slow me down and we can
back up and cover things in a little
more
detail um if we look at slide two we
have a mission statement there that
we've we've been exposed to more of the
the emphasis that I like to spend some
time on is um the functional areas of
Information
Services can may I suggest an update to
your mission at a future State I I I'd
really love to see you guys include in
your mission to uh to drive productivity
enhancements or something like
that I mean you're empowering employees
and citizens but I I we need more
productivity yep and I believe I believe
as a as a team that we do drive drive
that so that would be welcome
information to be able to incorporate
thank
you so our four four function areas main
function areas of Information Services
uh strategic planning
really that's that's listening and
evaluating and finding those
opportunities to improve the needs of
the the businesses across across the
department and I think that's that's an
important segue into this every everyone
that's presented today is really a
department-wide influence as opposed to
a single line of business so when we
look at the amount of people
that comprise Information Services to
include our project management office
um it's important to to realize that as
well the our our ability to be able to
take that time listen to the the
customers and then find the best
opportunities for those to fit into and
have the resolutions that we have uh
funding and ability for lies in that
strategic planning
area uh one of the
biggest attributes we're trying to do is
reduce that duplication by looking at
all of the different lines of businesses
across the 130 it systems that we have
responsibility to and
see how we can reduce duplication
streamline and have the most efficient
outcome for the entire
department artificial intelligence is a
something that we've been spending a lot
of
time trying to wrap our heads around so
that we can go about this correctly and
implement the things that have the
greatest
benefit um with a mentation of just
trying to broadly go after artificial
intelligence so right now we're spending
a lot of time in policy development and
researching how the department can best
benefit from it based on funding we'll
have the eight key platforms that the
department utilizes uh are listed here
with the exception of uh the Nexus
system that was a math eror on my part
we we uh the next system should be added
for the bureau of child support and
services as
well portfolio management the department
handles many different projects
technical projects usually end up being
a hybrid solution from a methodology
standpoint utilizing agile and than U
some of the waterfall principles and in
other cases with limited technology in
there they're going to be stronger on
waterfall so our portfolio management
really is organized for our project
management office acting as as a center
of excellence in putting the right
people in place to make those
determinations of of how to execute
those projects so jumping ahead how many
of those are employees versus
contract your project
managers uh we probably one of the
efforts that is a good accomplishment of
the project management office that it
acting as a center of excellence having
six positions that are actually project
manager
but have gone through and created the
training to stand up over 280 business
project managers in each of the business
lines so we've we've gone that route
excellent
question Asset Management um that's
handled within is as well that gives us
an opportunity to really manage life
cycle management keeping Pro
productivity up and having the proper
visibility to what's happening with our
with our equipment business intelligence
that's our ebi you'll hear a lot about
ebibi and that's we have our data
governance sits under
ebi and data management data
visualizations all our reporting
capabilities and
analytics information security um we
talked a little bit briefly about
privacy impact assessments coming into
to play and that's uh a strong Avenue
the uh data privacy and it security
governance board formed by your
legislation representative Edwards
actually just approved the Pia template
to be able to utilize and we have uh
been able to fill one of the positions
for supporting the the conducting of the
pasas
themselves if you look at the next slide
slide four it really is just a couple of
of points to be able to to see how we
exercise our
mission here it's driving improved
outcomes through enhanced decision-
making and productivity listed first and
some of the broad examples of how we
accomplish
that each of them paying individual
attention to how we Empower people
self-service options as far as
individuals out in the field doing the
work with our with the clients and
customers and giving them the proper
tools to be able to execute more
efficiently
reducing cost of
operation core Services we're going to
see examples of that how we've done that
from a system perspective when we get to
um slides further as
well any questions on the information
we've covered so far
nope oh representative
priest uh thank you Mr chairman and um
again back to your slide on page three
of your handout um is it's my
understanding that the staff that you
have the 19 or the 21 individuals that
you do have the 19 that you are that's
in the governor's budget share these
responsibilities is that correct or do
you have POS number of Staff in each one
of these
um you're correct yes the
responsibilities are shared in and then
divide it up around those key function
areas one one correction in there are uh
person that has the most knowledge so
far presenting today occupies one of
those positions from a number standpoint
I believe and uh David weeders is now
Chief Operating Officer so that leaves
us with an actual um staff of 20
positions okay thank
you 20 now but still 19 next year or is
it going to be 18
yes so in in state fiscal year 2627
there were two positions moved one was
moved to uh 5,000 which is the office of
commissioner accounting unit the other
one was moved to 7937 which is Medicaid
Administration so there's 19 positions
in state fiscal year 26 five are
unfunded three uh classified positions
are unfunded and two unclassified
positions are unfunded thank
you a question still representative
priest
you represent yeah very very very quick
question on page 1060 on line 66 is just
curious about the huge uh bump up in
fiscal year 2025 on on that line and
then kind of the
uh it just stuck out as a what what was
the explanation behind that sure um so
so just to clarify so we're looking at
the adjusted authorized amount and say
fiscal year 25 not necessarily what was
spent um this is related to the training
that Ernie was referring to where um we
we have sought to train um many of the
individuals across the department who
may not necessarily be a project manager
by training they may have a Social
Services background they have may have a
specialty in public health but basically
uh that money was is being used for
training those individuals uh to gain
the project management skills to help
them with their day-to-day uh tasks and
projects so that was like a a one-time
uh bump up because you had a lot of new
people with yes and and that's why in
the second in the 26 27 you see a pretty
significant drop off there okay thank
you I can elaborate just a little bit as
well just procedurally D changed their
their procedures for how we could go
about an occupy training and that meant
that to secure that training we'd have
to be on an RFP
process which puts us out Beyond a Time
an acceptable time that would' be able
to utilize those funds as
well just a quick followup so that so
that means not all that money's been
spent yet that's correct it has not been
spent
yet we we have needs to be able to put
in training but we have to make those
decisions to how to best prioritize that
and how we can accomplish it without
having to um contract and bring someone
in to be able to do so approximately
approximately how much remains unspent I
I I I would need to pull up the
statement of Appropriations report to
look at what outstanding incumbrances we
have and what's been spent year to date
to be able to get to that number um any
money that's projected to not be
utilized this uh particular bium would
either lapse if it was General funds or
it would be used against the remaining I
think roughly 11 or 12 million milon
doll back of the budget reduction that
we're required to um achieve uh pursuant
to uh to state law okay thank
you and if we uh jump forward to slide
five to take a look at the organizations
there five and six comprise all of uh
Information Services from a staffing
perspective uh I know the question came
up about what the vacancy rate was and
we're at 25 % vacancy
rate curly in our in the combined areas
of uh Information Services and
pmo so so what do you do when you get to
a certain vacancy percentage that uh
where you you just can't keep up with
the uh strategic plan and the and the
implementations do you do you do you
have a contract you rely on to bring in
additional contracted service support
well it's one of the items that would'
like to be able to discuss further in
the slide as well as what we do look
look for to be able to offset some of
the
gaps okay all
right in SL in slide seven we've
identified some of the key
accomplishments um again here we can run
through spend as much time on it but it
gives you a sense I think more
importantly is our it's our impact
really breaks down into the three
specific areas is a Statewide
department-wide as well as division
specific you
see first one for example the enterprise
resource planning and Cloud Suite
solution that involves um most all
aspects of of is from project management
to our ebi team and understanding
Integrations into our uh security
component as well be able to do that and
that translates through most every uh
effort that we work with across the
department one things that one of the
things that I'll mention CC Salesforce
listed in a couple different
places we have the uh we've had the
luxury of being able to have the funding
to grow Salesforce as a solution which
has filled a lot of gaps and done a
great job for our front pacing
aspects of there when we
develop aspects of Salesforce within
that solution that ends up being able to
be shared across the state as well so
it's a it's a a way
of duplicating different efforts to come
up with the same results so I think
that's that's been a a pretty big
success Department wide one thing that
I'll focus a little bit of time but
please ask any questions about about
anything specifically on there is that
that ability that we've
drawn to the Privacy impact assessments
and our work there um as Mr
weeders explained that the the direction
is to be uh consent in as our systems
are developed and that's that's been a
um an effort that's been going going on
as long as I've been here since 2019 to
try to turn
that Avenue everything that we look at
from a development standpoint really has
become more privacy
Centric and that's success that I've
seen over the over my time being here as
well so business intelligence coupled I
guess eventually with some
AI where where do you see probably the
number one most lucrative
deployment of business intelligence may
be in the department in terms of
improving Financial recoveries saving
costs through enhanced productivity what
where what what's our number one lwh
hanging fruit and yes Mr weers you're
welcome
to yes so it considering there is the
potential is is terrific it's just start
one that understanding I think one of
the things that we find the highest
value in incorpora from a department
wide aspect is um having AI involved
with our uh policy and in state laws and
regulations so that answers can come at
the Press of a button to anyone that is
customer facing and understand they're
doing the right
thing utilizing AI to be able to
populate that information to what we can
and how it should be
done okay I'm I'm looking for the top
project that we want to go after the so
so the the top project that we want to
go after is from two different lenses
one from a privacy where we were
planning on using a natural language
processing tool for um to create a a
knowledge base for a chatbot to be able
to be used by our staff to look at our
administrative rules our policies our
procedures and be able to do in real
time answers to questions on call
centers as well as for elig eligibility
determination redetermination so that we
don't have delays where we have
currently the process where our
individuals take anywhere from 6 to
months to a year to on board and learn
all those policies and procedures and
administrative rules they be able to use
that natural language processing tool to
immediately based off of prompts give
them information so they can do the
determinations in hours and and days as
opposed to weeks and months and so
that's and the reason why we wanted to
do that um specifically as the first
project was it doesn't manage any any
private information it's all public data
administrative rules policies and
procedures so we can prove out that we
can create a private natural language
processing knowledge base that can
manage the security and the privacy of
the information but also Drive
efficiency in our department we would
expand beyond that in the future to be
able to do um n um utilize AI to
actually program in what we call
business rules for determinations of
eligibility or other Solutions like
child support and whatnot but that would
require us to already have a proven
concept of ensuring the privacy of the
information first so that's how we we
sort of staged it we want to we don't
want to use data that has highly highly
regulated information we don't want to
violate our state constitution for
privacy in inadvertently by using like a
Google or an AWS or
Microsoft um tool but we believe that if
we go in those steps we'll get to that
point of being being able to leverage it
to a better return on investment as you
indicated earlier sounds good when when
you guys come up with like a strategic
plan on how you plan on rolling that out
and developing it I I I would be
interested in seeing that and I would
hope that U Miss tus tell us would have
a lot of input in there because it
struck me as she gave her presentation
that there may be a lot of opportunity
to help with sort of the behavior
identification or she's looking for
misbehavior misbehavior identification
and and uh
unusual uh submissions that should be
flagged and looked at I just seem it
seems like a Target Rich environment but
all
right thanks
absolutely go
ahead oh uh representative
Stringham um could you expand at all on
line 27 um uh you know roughly 50
million line how many uh how how does
how does that get spent and uh
appropriated where does it go what's the
process to decide how to spend that so
yes thank you I sure can the um so again
with all the uh Department of
responsibilities from a system
standpoint the that's this comprises the
operational budget of all those systems
so we generate that in uh cooperation
and collaboration with doit for
understanding those needs uh put those
funds together to be able to support all
of the systems in play across the
department that's what that funding line
is
for so so is this is this somewhere else
in the budget that they they show this
48 million in roughly which was 24 is
that important element too is doit
supports DHHS through their Staffing as
well and these numbers are in uh part of
that
offset yes I I believe division one
covers the department of Information
Technology so there's an equivalent
transfer line located in their budget
and if you look in in the governor's
operating budget if you do uh ever look
at page
1064 what you will see down there at the
bottom is you will see the federal funds
the general funds education trust fund
other funds and then you'll see less
funds for budgeted Revenue transfers and
the number that will be found there is
that 54 and55 million that you see in
class 27 because that money is being
moved over to the Department of
Information Technology and being
accounted for
there all right the next slide slide
eight basically just direct you to to
the area that we're looking at now in
the budget
book Slide N really was just a
visualization of the of the systems in
play that center around the road map um
commitments
here we weren't going to spend much time
on that unless there specific questions
on it but did want to be able to
visually tie in um the systems that are
supporting those goals
slide
10 I'm just going to ask uh Nathan to
kind of talk to before I get into
details a bit sure so this is just
following up on uh representative walner
request from yesterday as far as listing
out the prioritized needs um that were
funded or not funded in the agency's
budget um when we prepare I I think just
for background and context for for some
of the members that are newer to this
process we prepare our agency budget
back in August when we when we prepare
that agency budget there's two major
components to it there's the efficiency
expenditure budget which is basically
what your cost to continue Baseline
operations and then there is the
governor's directive and the governor um
his directive May potent he or she uh
May potentially run slightly counter to
what the efficiency expenditure is based
on Revenue projections um that need to
be accounted for and so when we prepared
our original efficiency budget some
baseline efficiency cost cost such as
some of the state fiscal year 24
legislation SP 463 SP uh 1573 some of
those items were included as prioritized
need because we were unable to get to
the Target that we were given um there
are a number of key IT projects uh
listed here um two of which we talked
about earlier relative to the Salesforce
the the budget intelligence system as
well as the docy sign system and I just
kind of want to provide some of that
context uh obviously there's a lot of
hard choices that have to be made during
the the budget process um but currently
uh these are these are some of the
system enhancements or efficiencies that
we were unable to get within our initial
efficiency budget that are currently
unfunded and I'll hand it over to
Ernie uh representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman again on this
page 10 could you just briefly describe
the new heights efficiency consolidation
in the cell Force I'm just not familiar
with those two
uh sure projects so the new heights is
our eligibility system that's utilized
for many different aspects of uh our
services across across the department
one of the things where I'm talking
about it here is a large portion of the
efficiency aspect was carved out of it
um and the important aspects to bring in
as as an effort to be efficient and
consolidate some of the systems utilized
AC elsewhere in the department they were
brought into New Heights to
accomplish what had to happen for those
individual systems as new heights could
take that but it also meant that it was
an expanded use of new heights which
requires additional maintenance
enhancements and refinements to be able
to monitor all those additions as
well okay what about Salesforce
development Salesforce development is is
the area that we have um seen a lot of
benefits by creating a system systems
such as uh Incident Management System
our
constituent inquiry and response
system and uh Incident Management System
just to expand a little bit has has
provided
solutions from several areas New
Hampshire hospital for example
dcyf um we have um in public health we
have the immunization information system
that's
utilizing the uh Incident Management
System as well as uh dpq in their
Century
events that are being utilized as
well what is what the Salesforce has
done for us is be able to answer a lot
of the questions that have been business
problems um working through spreadsheets
and trying to have a have a solution
that is a very usable front-end aspect
for solving that and then our ability to
be able to tie in the data that we
collect within the Salesforce to be able
to integrate that with the other systems
to have a full benefit around that to
include ebi and our uh document
Management Systems as
well as a followup on that same page did
you prepare a like a cost benefit
analysis we have the cost of these
programs that were not funded but do you
have like a a dollar figure of the
benefits of savings that would happen if
these programs were funded to not only
the department but also to the state we
don't have one um developed here but
glad to be able to provide that
information I I I I think one easy
number to point back to is what we
talked about this morning um when we
were looking at the federal funds that
we were no longer lapsing while it may
not be a perfect year-to-year
comparison um the
the the the general funds that we were
able to offset when we budgeted were in
the tens of millions of dollars um and
that's a several hundred, system that
falls within the Salesforce development
team that's the kind of work at least on
the finance side obviously there's
different types of work that are going
on across the department um but I don't
think we have a a formal comprehensive
department-wide analysis to address that
exact question that would be very
beneficial in the future but to come up
with I'll take that back so I actually
think there's an easy low hanging fruit
one here um on the bottom of uh page 10
the E signature solution I I think we
heard testimony earlier that if we went
back to uh chasing down wet ink
signatures that that would uh create U
not only time lags but it would also
cost a tremendous amount of manpower to
run around chasing this down so so to me
it's a very simple little business case
justification what do we think the manh
hour impact and what would do we think
the delay getting contract signed what
what what what's the cost of that
relative to the 346,000 in uh General
funds and if you started with a low
hanging fruit one we could kick it back
around a little bit and and see how it
feels whether or not it's worth pursuing
similar to what representative priest
just suggested for the the other ones
sure that makes sense that's my guess
that's the easiest one to do if I may I
would I would agree with you
representative Edwards most of the goals
of our technology is to improve
productivity reduce duplication of
effort the return on investment is
reducing error errors in in doing work
and also improving the efficiency of
those services so just just as a
component of the Salesforce development
team that represents seven outside
contractors
for one year so let's not do do do each
one let's just let's just take as many
as you want to give us something back so
we can look at but we need a business
case much like representative priest
just said certainly we can take that
back and get you I don't know that we
could consider these without in the
absence of okay so what is the return on
investment I think we will certainly
take that back and give you a couple of
examples of the return on investment of
this team that the one component that
you'll see in that example is that this
is an agile team so it works on features
and fun and epics which means that might
be deploying a budget system today and
then a constituent management system in
a month and then another system the
following month and we're constantly
evaluating um different products as we
go forward so that we don't limit
ourselves to one solution that we can
actually streamline and improve multiple
Solutions sure I'd just suggest the
first one that we go kick back and forth
we we remember the kiss principle just
keep it keep it simple for the stupid
just tell you know we we'll bring that
back we'll send that W did you have a
question this is a question for uh Mr
White this is the first time today that
we've seen this
um page entitled unfunded areas impacted
does that mean that in the other are
areas that we went through today that
there were no
um
priority yeah so priorities the only
other area was the the
$102,000 each year for the LinkedIn uh
HR um resource um D just due to the
because we've only had a pretty small
window to prepare these and update them
based on the governor's budget coming
out we weren't able to update that
particular slide but in all the other
division slides that will be presented
you will be seeing the same duplicated
or something similar uh that will be
captured at the end there but that's the
only one that that we weren't able to
get everything 100% in order and just
preparing all these on a pretty quick
turnaround time frame great thank you of
course helpful representative
priest thank you Mr chairman um uh back
to the discussion on the AI I'm I'm glad
you're uh use utilizing AI in your
current Services is that
correct um thank you for the question
not yet we are looking to to doing that
are there safeguards to protect the
agency and the people of New Hampshire
and and that is entirely why we're doing
most of as um Mr gilan indicated we're
focusing on policy procedure first and
then we're going to focus on a natural
language processing tool for public data
that's already out there in the public
to prove the solution improve out this
privacy and security component so that
we can look at the policy implement the
policy with the solution that if it has
any leakage or qu data quality issues
that is public information anyway so
we're not having a high risk and then
from there we'll refine our policy and
procedures to ensure that the the more
protective uh the Privacy um regulated
data that we manage if we move into that
in in the future that it wouldn't be um
protected as a state solution not a open
AI
solution as a followup um so the
information that you're collecting now
for Medicare and
Medicaid uh in this state and the fact
that it's you know we have a provision
in our constitution to really value
privacy um are there anything that you
can and I'm sure that you share that
information with the federal
government is that correct federal
agencies that you're getting funding
from yeah but this is kind of a I'm
sorry no it's just F you just you know
you started talking about Ai and how
we're going to roll Ai and now you're
talking about data sharing with the
federal government and other third
parties with it's just a different
subject thank you for uh pointing that
out all right I really appreciate ask
whatever question you ask okay going
back to the information sharing um with
the federal government um again what
Provisions do you have to kind of
Safeguard the information that we are
collecting here in the
state it this is separate of yeah
relevant to AI all right so David you
want to exp sure it it depends on the
data set so every like Medicaid has
specific Regulatory and um state and
federal laws governing that information
who we can share it with so we follow
those state and federal laws I can take
that like from Medicaid I would go back
to Henry Litman our Medicaid director on
how he would manage sharing data with
our federal Partners um but in every
case we follow that we identify what
laws are are the data is governed by and
then we com create data sharing
agreements where are necessary or
information exchange agreements is what
we usually do with our federal Partners
or memorandums of understandings with um
within our our state departments to
share the information and within those M
us we work through our privacy officer
to ensure that we know exactly what
Fields we're sharing who we're sharing
them with that we have legal authority
to share them with those those entities
and if we don't then we don't we don't
purs it we don't move forward with
sharing okay thank you and I and again I
I apologize no you're fine you're you're
great uh the the and then the final ring
in the defense in depth is is uh
Meredith ts's group is doing audits to
ensure compliance with state federal law
so there's there's yet another layer of
kind of an independent oversight to make
sure that we're following data sharing
uh regulations and and
agreements I I believe that's true is is
it not she does review the data sets and
make sure that we're following all the
the the regs through an audit to ensure
that we're sharing with the right people
and for the right reasons yeah so it
sounds like you have a nice defense in
depth approach to protecting dat data
privacy I believe we
do represent Stringham yeah just a uh
just a little bug you know Hippa is
HIPAA
uh so it's Hippa
Hippa in a bunch of the documents uh but
uh uh going back in in you know looking
at the E signature Solutions have you
looked at things like Panda do or other
systems you know you're wondering now
that this class of software is
established are there cheaper equally
highly reliable systems that we could
use and get all the benefits that we've
had in accelerated Contracting and
reduced uh improved staff efficiency in
generating cont contracts without
necessarily um uh using um docy sign
thanks yeah the sorry yeah the um we're
we're always looking to be able to have
the best product to be able to do the
the uh services that we want to
accomplish on there docu sign
specifically met that need at uh a very
crisis point during our uh covid aspect
as one of the one of the leaders to be
able to accomplish that but yes as
Staffing allows and we're able to put
more effort into strategy then we want
to be able to innovate and be using the
the best products we can I I I I think
one important consideration though is
when when you build one of these systems
I mean building a road is may not may
not be the best metaphor but you spent
the time to Define your business
requirements to work with the work with
the the contractor for the solution work
with your team to train them and you
worked with in the case of docy sign
like our vendor and the Attorney
General's office and so we've come up
with sort of a comprehensive solution
that you know didn't happen overnight
but um but it and it's also not only in
in the contract sphere it's in the
public health sphere and working on the
uh division of longterm long-term
supports and services sphere so well
something may like nominally be cheaper
there may be that investment cost
upfront as well as your loss
productivity cost that you just have to
balance out when looking at that
and so so I I I I have a homework
assignment I think for you on page uh 11
under
Consultants
525,000 would would you would you please
um break that out for me in terms of the
number of hours and what the average
hourly price of an hour is sure and and
then for a comparison a
baseline uh give me a fully load loed uh
employed uh employee of the state fully
loaded I mean all the benefits in the
whole the whole deal uh and what um an
an effective hourly rate would be for a
wellp paid um employee total cost of
that employee yes yes Absolut because I
I just want to see what we're what we're
trading off when we don't have employees
we're we're paying uh consultants and
and what I I'd like to understand what
tradeoff we're making sure and that
makes sense and I think one of the
aspects of identifying the consultant
Parts here is that it really becomes
that ad hoc ability that we not they're
not on the payroll all the time right
that their ability to be able to stand
it in but I'm happy to make that
comparison it's an excellent point uh
just just remind me of that when you you
Pro provide the other data yes sir all
right okay any other questions okay do
you have any closing thoughts did did we
hit everything you you wanted us to hear
go I think so and I think you know
Nathan had had framed it up we we had
prioritized needs we did not submit any
prioritized needs here everything we're
asking for is a way for us to be you
know as we see more efficient productive
in what we're accomplishing all right
well thank thank you I think facilities
is up next thank
you and I don't see a a PowerPoint for
the facilities is there no PowerPoint is
it I I think it's out of order I um I I
I I think it ended up getting slid
behind office of Health Equity there but
on the schedule facilities is next so um
once you find the PowerPoint um it it
should be labeled it should be in there
um there's two account units here and U
it begins in the governor's operating
budget on page
1,57 and the accounting unit is
5685 and then there's also a second
accounting unit
5687 on page 1,58 so they're sequential
so they're together so it's a little
easier good and then in the budget
briefing book um the accounting unit for
management report 5685 begins on page
26 and the second accounting unit does
not have uh an entry in the budget
briefing book because it is below a
million dollar and with that said I will
hand it over to Tammy Nelson our
director of
facilities so on page 26 it's labeled
management support or am I on the wrong
page that is
correct okay
welcome thank you good just state your
name for the clerk good afternoon my
name is Tammy Nelson I'm the director of
facilities and office services this
afternoon I'll walk you through a brief
slide deck that starts with our mission
the focus and functions of our work a
high level or chart and close with some
specific details about our district
offices our mission to provide and
manage safe accessible and C C efficient
facilities slide three as part of our
portfolio we managed 26 lease agreements
with 11 of them being for the regional
office locations that are referred to as
our district offices the district
offices are located throughout the state
as shown in slide8 for the purpose of
serving DHHS clients our district
offices total approximately 229,000
Square ft of least office space housing
approximately 1,000 program staff
further we provide oversight and
management support of the Department's
247 facilities each each institution has
a facilities manager and maintenance
staff who are directly responsible to
oversee facility
operations however there is ongoing
collaboration with general maintenance
emergency repairs resource allocation
special or unplanned projects and
identifying capital projects
slide four details a variety of our core
functions to include lease
Administration space utilization
insuring compliance with safety
regulations and Ada
accessibility the supply of furniture
fixtures equipment and general
maintenance further Services include the
administration of office services which
support all of our HHS locations
throughout the state that includes mail
purchasing inventory And archiving
Logistics
telecommunications transportation and
Fleet Management
Services Slide Five provides a highlevel
org
chart you'll see that we have um myself
and we have four administrators one that
oversees Regional operations one that
oversees lease Administration one that
oversees office services and one that
oversees maintenance
services slide six highlights a few key
projects um that we've done over this
current budget to include the relocation
of the Claremont district office to
better serve both staff and clients the
New Hampshire hospital Lobby upgrades
following the tragic events of November
2023 and various furnit up Furniture
upgrades due to aged equipment and
safety concerns
slide eight um as noted previously shows
the geographic layout of the district
offices we are um as high up as Berlin
um all the way down to
nashaa slide nine shows where the 247
facilities are
located and slide 10 shows um a closer
look at our district offices in terms of
footage staff counts and renewal
dates and that essentially wraps up the
overview okay that's great the the the
things I get curious about when I look
at facilities is um
uh what what are your longer term plans
I I I know we we've got to be planning
for shutting down and turning over the
sonunu Youth Development Center uh I if
that's going to if that's going to be
completed in this budget cycle then I we
I don't need to worry about a budgetary
impact not this budget but if we're
going to be able to turn over the sonunu
Youth Development Center to das that
could potentially save the department
money in this budget cycle so I I just
want to understand timing around
turnover plan turn turn over of the senu
Youth Development
Center so at a at a higher level I'll
take that question if that's okay
representative sure um so at a high
level the Youth Development Center is as
we stated earlier I think a week or two
ago yeah had Broken Ground over it in
Hamstead and is currently on track for
being completed or um completed in
2026 and then we would need to then
occupy so the Occupy OCC occupy and run
YDC over at that new location is as we
discussed in the previous session
dependent on some of the ad alternates
that were not funded and would delay our
ability to actually operate in that
building if we aren't able to obtain the
additional funds to in include the
cultural Corridor laundry services um
cafeteria or food services so so the
summary of that is until you understand
what your operational budget is for the
new center you can't reasonably uh
anticipate a closure date of the old
suoo center that is a very concise way
of saying what I was saying yes Mr chair
all right all right uh I understand um
and then uh I I want to know when you
all are going to present the 10-year
plan for
glencliffe cuz you know I love Glen
Cliffe it's a beautiful resort-like
environment uh with 500y old buildings
or something like that uh at some point
uh it's going to be untenable to be
maintaining those buildings and I want
to know that we have people paying
attention to the escalating cost of
Maintenance versus the building of new I
I I I I just would like to know I don't
want the answer in this budget cycle
because the answer doesn't impact this
budget cycle I don't think maybe there's
some maintenance cost when we get to
Glen Cliffe but but we we really need to
we really need to understand what the
long-term plan is for Glen Cliffe we
can't just assume we're going to be
operating at another 20 years I don't
think so so for the current bium uh Glen
Cliff has been funded at approximately
the the the 75 census um uh patient
patient census um I I I think that's a
much larger more comprehensive
conversation well in advance of
facilities I think if if we're to
discuss that further I'd like to have um
Ellen Le Point here the CEO of New
Hampshire hospital who helps over who
oversees Glen Cliffe but I think that's
a much broader conversation than just
facilities it absolutely is and so
that's why I'm just asking when can we
start to expect to hear what the
Department's plan is I you guys can have
all the conversation you want I just
want to know when we could start to
expect to you know hear what you're
thinking is about the lot the the the
life cycle of Glen Cliffe and the
replacement I I don't need to have an
opinion I'm just curious when you guys
will have one
developed um not today no um and again I
I I think it's a much broader
conversation not really prepared to
discuss today
okay um so uh I I I'm not prepared to
ask questions about the the the line
item budget are there questions from the
members um uh go ahead representative
priest I just wanted to commend um the
director of facilities you do an amazing
job of of the facilities that we own and
operate uh a group of us went to Glen
cliff last spring and considering how
old the facility is and it's still an
operation but yet you're managing to
keep it going it's amazing thank you so
much thank
you that's all true I agree I I
um I do now have another question though
with with the way the corporate world is
going uh as as people do more remote
work is there's consolidation
opportunities do you do you see any
opportunity if not in this budget cycle
but a a upcoming one where we ought to
be doing a serious condol consolidation
of office space to uh reduce our
footprint I'd like to defer that to Dave
please sure so actually we have been
doing that since covid time so Public
Health um was the sort of the champion
for that so they would have about 30 to
50% of their staff remote at any given
time so we do a hoteling is what I call
it where there's shared workspaces and
they they LED that way and then as we
move forward we are doing that in
Information Services in conjunction with
um economic stability where we Hotel
space in Brown building so that we
didn't when we actually were moved out
of the South Street location and
Department of Corrections moved in we
didn't need to go out and Lease
additional building space and we were
able to reuse of the space within Brown
building so we are looking in that at
that as an opportunity um especially
when there's deferred maintenance on
buildings that administrative Services
doesn't always get the funding for that
they need we're looking to see how we
can do that as we go forward and one of
the things that we also did is
consolidating our warehouse space we had
two warehouses we're now down to one
through this budget um so we are
constantly looking at our space
utilization so then you probably also
have an answer for um you know as you as
you go into the onto the campus and you
take that first sort of uh bank and the
main building is there um the old main
building to the left of it is a is a
ghost building it's abandoned and
boarded up do you know which one I'm
talking about I believe I
do what's the plan for that that would
be bankof that is a building that is
owned and managed by the department of
administrative Services okay we'd have
to refer to so we're not paying for it
the department isn't we are not all
right that's
good um I I don't have any more
questions on facilities anyone else have
questions on facilities to you rep
representative okay very good thank you
thank
you you and you didn't have a a
backslide on unfunded
priorities all right
there um in
5685 there are two unfunded
positions um in the class 10 line and
then there is one unfunded position in
the class 12 line and then in uh DHHS
distri district office the accy unit
5687 there's one unfunded position in
class
okay all
right so with
that I think we're ready for Mr Hampton
office of Health
Equity commissioner do you want to step
up as well or you're you're good where
you're
at
okay you you you you can enjoy the seat
that Mr weers just uh evacuated so Ju
Just to orient the committee um there
there's going to be uh two primary
accounting units um with the office of
Health Equity and the first is on page,
142 in the governor's operating budget
it's accy unit 7208 minority Health
Refugee Affairs and then the second is
on page
1043 it's accounting unit
7209 and it's Refugee
services and in the budget briefing
book it is included on page
um um so the first accounting unit
7208 begins on page seven of the budget
briefing book and the second begins on
page 9 for
7209 um of the budget briefing book and
continues uh through page
12 and with that I will hand it over to
Ruben Hampton our
director good afternoon I'm Ruben
Hampton the director of the office of
Health Equity I'll be taking you through
the office's Mission uh some of the key
outcomes at a high level if we achieve
that mission and uh key accomplishments
along with an organizational
chart the mission of the office is to
identify and mitigate Health disparities
for all of New Hampshire that's on page
two and if you flip that to page three
uh you'd see that for a key outcome
number one it would be that uh all folks
in the state would have Equitable access
to the programs and services of the
department one way we would make that
happen is by ensuring that the
department all of its Partners all the
vendors all the community organizations
that we work with are providing cultur
linguistically appropriate services and
whether that's policies procedures the
actual interpreters translation services
themselves and not just for compliance
reasons which are important but also so
we can provide more effective services
to those that we
serve if you move to the next slide
slide four there's also the community
outreach and
engagement portion to make sure that we
as a department are staying engaged with
Community State holders at the office we
try to build relationships with folks
across the state from all different
backgrounds uh it's important that
whether it's different divisions groups
subgroups when they there are programs
and services are able to work with
different parts of the community uh get
their input get their participation as
needed as appropriate and we try to
facilitate those relationships on the
flip side of that it's also important
that Community voice be involved with
these programs that you know are
designed to serve them as well as the
development of new
programs and for the refugee program
specifically there are some high level
goals from the federal government but
overall we want to ensure that folks are
able to get settled here integrated and
achieve self-sufficiency in addition to
if they have kids get those folks in
school uh provide on the job training
and also receive any necessary
Healthcare treatment and screening up
front so I'm I'm going to ask you a
question there I I I was um I was in
Afghanistan for a year and interacted
directly with that population and I know
that from a refugee perspective we
brought in at one point I think the
count was 120 I don't know what the
total count is as of now maybe you could
tell me the Afghan population But but so
my concern having having interacted with
that culture on their ground and their
turf was that
uh relative to us standards there was a
a huge amount of work that could be done
or maybe ought to be done to make sure
that women were were fully integrated
into society and that they were able to
go to school they were able to play
sports they were able to get uh good
access to health care you know uh can
you can you speak I'm not asking for
names or personal identifying data of
any kind but I I'd like to understand
your perspective on how good a job we've
been doing at the cultural integration
of the Afghan
refugees there's been a lot of work to
ensure this comes from we partner with
now five different vendors for Refugee
Services broadly two resettlement
agencies three other service providers
who all would work with uh different
groups and whether that's trying to
ensure that from Pure linguistic
standpoint we provide uh interpreters or
service providers that speak uh the
different Native languages that are uh
Afghani refugees or sivs or other folks
that are coming over speak that they
have folks that they want to work with
that uh are able to understand their
culture uh the agencies have invested in
that staff they also spend extensive
time with the families I've personally
aware of a couple different family
situations where the office and the
retem agency have partnered together to
meet the needs of families to ensure
that they're happy whether that means
that they are in New Hampshire or they
out migrate to a different state as well
so there has been substantial investment
to ensure that there is cult integration
and that they are meeting the needs of
their families because I I just I need
to interrupt you just for a second
you're you're doing a great job of
telling me what we're doing my question
was how are we
doing are are we doing are are have we
achieved what we consider to be success
in terms of the successful cultural
integration of the Afghan population yes
or
no or it's not really a yes or no but
I'd like to hear more about the h how
are we doing and not what are we doing
my understanding is as well as it can be
expected given the circumstances you
have a lot of folks who you know came
over under duress to say the least and
you know coming over to a brand new
country but it is going as well as can
be expected and them coming here having
to start a whole new life and uh being
able to integrate into society to get
jobs to get their kids into schools to
get house housing I'm particularly
concerned about are are we helping to
make sure that the women are enjoying
American freedoms and
opportunity there have
been for my specific knowledge
that workers for the individual
resettlement agencies for uh folks from
the office have met with individual
family members as well to ensure that
their needs are met so from my
understanding that is true
do do you want to add to that
commissioner good afternoon an Le Andrew
associate commissioner thank you um
chairman Edwards I I would reiterate
what Ruben is saying I do remember us
discussing this I think two years ago
maybe at the last by a.m and and with
some of our acceptance accepts and
expends along the way um we're lucky
that you know the the two resettlement
two primary resettlement agencies here
in New Hampshire are are belong to the
you know nine nine national federal
resettlement agencies and these
organizations are well equipped to do
that work to integrate any you know any
Refugee um who comes to the US they hire
as Ruben said they hire they invest in
it and and we have no reason to believe
that they're not s being successful in
that today and I I think um part of that
sorry if I can just finish I didn't mean
to interrupt is um is looking at what
are those cultural comp competencies
that the families um and the communities
need to integrate those families and and
for your example here um how that may
different from their home country here
in America so yeah right yes do do do we
have performance metrics that inform our
own people uh on how well we're doing as
opposed to Counting what we're doing
because I think that would be easy I I
want to know how we're doing do we have
performance measure measurements to tell
us how we're
doing the federal program has very
specific metrics that we must keep track
of and report on that are it's a more
performance-based they don't necessarily
speak to some of the cultural aspects
that you're talking about we certainly
keep track of and take very seriously
any feedback we do get from clients
individual family members and
investigate those followup with vendors
to ensure that needs are being met
whether they're from our Afghan clients
or other and that has happened in the
past and we absolutely do follow up so
I'm most familiar with the Afghans uh
what what other significant in terms of
numbers ref Refugee populations have we
welcomed to New Hampshire and are do do
we have any uh cultural integration
issues with any of those populations
there's been nothing to my knowledge
answer your second question first uh
that have been unexpect in terms of
cultural integration issues again as
people are coming over from a new
country under duress uh in terms of
larger populations the largest have been
the humanitarian PES from Ukraine have
been a larger population uh Afghans
previously not as much currently were a
larger population and the rest not NE
particular outliers we've had a somewhat
larger population from the DRC but
that's uh relative not necessarily as
high as DRC uh Democratic Republic of
Congo okay thank you and but we have not
had that's not at the same relative
scale as Afghanistan or Ukraine did did
I see a statistic that said that we have
over 7,000 refugees currently living in
New Hampshire like 7200 or
something do you do you do you know the
total number of refugees that we we have
in New Hampshire I'd have to get back to
you with that data to confirm how many
are living in the state because a lot of
folks out migrate as well right we we
track you know who arrives into the
state year by year I would have to get
back to you on how many are currently in
the state we don't the number that
arrive is in the low hundreds it's not
in the thousands so that okay and I'll
go to representative priest next but I I
um and then do we have any uh
in insight into a new pipeline of
refugees we might be expecting are we
are with the new Administration are we
getting any sort of communication on
what sort of uh Refugee resettlement we
may be looking at in the next year or
two the current Administration has put a
four-month hold on reception and
placement for refugees specifically so
those who would have Refugee status so
there are not any refugees coming over
uh
they've also attempted to do something
similar for humanitarian peoes you do
have some with special immigrant Visas
so sivs so actually some folks from
Afghanistan have come over but they've
there's been a significant drop off you
may have seen in the news that there
were uh some Afghan refugees and sivs on
a flight that was supposed to come over
that was cancelled right so there's been
a a significant drop off okay
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman again on a
as a continuation from what
representative Edwards has talked about
just recently um I think it would be
very helpful if we could get a table of
all the refugees that you have service
within the last five years and their
status in New
Hampshire thank you representative
clarifying question when you say there's
status uh if they're still living in the
state or if they've uh migrated out
understood I I I will see what we we're
able to provide that would be great
thank you so much and and with that
there are other groups like you
mentioned that there's a category on
humanitarian and the like I'll interpret
Refugee as the broad Refugee term when
you when you say that like humanitarian
proles refugees the generally the folks
of or office of refugee resettlement
eligible population folks that we serve
out outstanding thank you representative
nalo and then representative torki yes
uh thank you uh Mr Hampton for taking
taking the questions back to to page
three and your handouts I'm wondering if
you could provide a distinction between
equal and
Equitable General distinction there is
that uh you wouldn't equal has an
implication sometimes of providing the
same
uh solution for every person uh
Equitable often has the implication of
providing uh what each person needs
right for example you may have someone
uh from a disability perspective who
needs a specific solution versus someone
who does not you would inly provide them
with these same solution yeah that that
actually wasn't my question because this
is related to access and I think that's
a you've answered a a different question
so I always thought that our goal and
objective was equal equal access and I'm
not sure I understand how that
difference differs from
Equitable in this
case irrespective of the the the
difference between the to the the goal
is to ensure that regardless of their
particular circumstances whether you
know the person has a disability where
they're located in the state regardless
of their income they're Etc they're able
to access the Department's Services uh
in the same way that any other person
could that is what is intended by
Equitable okay thank you representative
torki and then represent sew thank you
very much I want to commend your very
small staff and what is probably a huge
impact on this um group of people who
come here in are very unique situation
so thank you for that um I may have
jumped ahead a little bit but I'm
looking at the key accomplishments of
your group and what caught my eye was
the bottom of page seven where it talks
about employment now we all know we have
a Workforce crisis here in our state um
and I've seen many uh economists sort of
reflect on if our immigration and and
influx of of um newcomers slows down we
may be in for a real problem here so I
was pleased to see some of these
initiatives and I'm wondering if you
could maybe just give me a little more
details I'm I'm being from NASA and I
know the child care crisis a child care
training program with greater
nationville United Way um can you talk a
little bit about what some of these
services are in order to get these um
people up and on their feet in a
job I'd be happy to thank you
representative
the general goal of the program is to
ensure folks are employed but also to
make sure that they're economically
mobile as well so that if there's
opportunities for training whether
that's specific skill related whether
that's language liberated they're able
to achieve it and a lot of our partners
are able to work with
us and local Community Partners when I
say Partners first I meant you know
vendors the resettlement agencies the
service providers to help set up
training programs uh for clients uh
something not included on here is
actually one of the resettlement
agencies is working to set up um a Child
Care Program and refugees who had the
proper training would actually be able
to uh work there as well uh they've
worked to set up licensing certification
programs that uh
refugees and clients are able to
participate in and you know able to
receive uh certification so they can
continue to work in different areas and
potentially higher paying roles as well
uh there's overall data that suggests
the current executive administration at
the federal level uh conducted a study
during their first term that looking at
15 years of data from 2004 to 2019
showing that refugees contributed more
in revenue and and cost less and
expenses than every other type of
Resident and even if you accounted for
the cost of their entire family they
still contributed more in Revenue than
the cost in expenses so generally
speaking as you suggest they're uh
valuable contributors from an economic
perspective thank you very much for that
I appreciate
it representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman
um I want to look at the budget line for
this and if you could help me under
understand there's kind of a a down and
back up in the in the budget where the
2025 columns lower could you explain
that Which accounting unit are you
referring to so this is on the refugees
uh page
1043 and the number is you can either
look at the federal revenues or the
total spending for the Department
because they
equal m so the um
so so so the the the question is why was
the actual expense higher than the
adjusted authorized in 20 in
2025 yes or conversely wi is 2025 kind
of stand out as the authorized expense
so much lower sure so one thing that
we've seen happen in this current bium
and um members of the fiscal committee
are familiar with this we've had to come
back through um since the original
budget was passed for the current bium
and accept a diff additional Federal
Awards uh through that fiscal process
and so we I don't remember the exact
number but it was in the millions of
dollars of additional funding that we
received um in in in subsequent Awards
after the budget was approved that that
are represented in the actual expense
those funds were added to those to the
refugee contracts that we have with our
providers in the community um I think
one really important thing just to point
out for the committee this is a 100%
federally funded program by the by the
federal government and so it can be
difficult to project what award amount
we may get um sort of as rubben alluded
to we don't necessarily know what the
policy of the federal government will be
we don't know what humanitarian crisises
may be occurring in the next two years
and and so we will from time to time see
significant fluctuations in the federal
funding that we receive that we did not
anticipate and as he suggested we in the
past have received influx of funds
particularly for the Afghan population
for the ukrainians as well during those
uh programs and so we are just told here
are the funds please uh try to expend
these as soon as you can and get them
contracted as soon as you can so in in
light of that the projection going
forward of it looks like around a 10%
increase how confident or not
confident is the 26 27 number
I I think it's important to remember
that we prepared this back in August um
things may have looked a little
differently back in August than they do
today um so uh we can certainly take
that back and and try to project what we
may think may happen um we could revise
the federal funds downward if we do that
then we just run the risk of having to
come back through fiscal to accept
additional federal funds that we didn't
anticipate this is just part of the U
part of The Balancing Act here where we
can't control what's driving the expense
and the
revenue so I'm I'm um I'm looking at the
number of positions on page
1043 uh for the refugee
Services uh I I want to understand the
three um if if there were not another
single Refugee brought to New Hampshire
how how many of these people would we
need to retain
and I I don't I shouldn't have said
people I I really mean positions because
I I have no clue who these folks
are so we currently have three vacancies
on that team one of which you know it's
particularly important the health
coordinator position so all of these are
vacant currently the the three on the
org chart you'll look and see that
there's the health coordinator position
that's vacant the data analyst and the
Outreach coordinator uh the in in stes
the two that are always mentioned in in
statute are the state Refugee
coordinator and the health coordinator
Health coordinator was due to the high
ring freeze we could not make a hire uh
it all of these the those three
positions that are filled in the health
coordinator position would all still be
valuable because You' still have folks
in the state who still need to be served
you could also still have clients who
come from different states and even if
you don't have refugees who come in
let's say the four Monon pause is
extended you would still have potential
folks coming from different Pathways
like sivs ases who are still going to
need services and
assistance that's also why we have two
of the positions vacant and on hold the
data specialist and the Outreach
coordinator that we have not sought to
fill given the current state of the
program at the federal level okay and
and similarly talk about the positions
that are under under uh minority health
and Refugee Affairs give give us an idea
of I know what the one unclassified
position is but talk talk us through the
the
six on permanent
classified so these are in we have the
two communication access roles um which
deal with uh a myriad of requests uh
often related to compliance we train uh
folks in internally externally vendors
uh work to improve our internal systems
and processes again to provide you know
better services in addition to the
compliance pieces uh there is the
administrative role which will also be
assisting with the communication access
pieces given available bandwidth uh we
have a community outreach and engagement
role that we have filled for the
community outreach and engagement pieces
the other is on hold due to the hiring
freeze and we have the behavioral health
listic competence coordinator which is
going to be assisting with community
outreach also helps with communication
access as well and does some trainings
couple for Behavioral Health for example
QPR Mental Health First
Aid so show of the 11 it sounds like you
have four currently that are vacant and
subject to a hiring freeze yes uh two of
them we were at the reference stage four
and uh can proceed no further two of
them we were going to keep on hold
depending what's going on with the
refugee program at the federal level
first category of the first two I I'm
not sure I've heard that term so to uh
we were about we were at the reference
stage for we were we were doing
reference checks for and we had the
whole oh so they thought they were going
to be employed because we started a
reference check and then we froze I
can't I can't speak to the the thought
there but yes we were very close hiring
free hit so we can not fill them two of
the refugee program positions we
intended to keep on hold depending
what's going on at the federal level and
and what kind of job descriptions are
these what kind of skill set or
education are are you requiring so for
the two the state Refugee Health
coordinator has a pretty specific skill
set because you want someone with a
refugee background and also the health
background as well because they have to
have familiarity with the type of exams
that refugees must go under and the
healthcare infrastructure but also
Refugee resettlement generally uh the
community outreach role you'd want
someone who has experience in community
outreach engagement but also strategy as
well when it comes to looking at the
state and uh what gaps do we have what
do we need so those for those two rol
specifically at a high Lev and you're
able to find people with Refugee
backgrounds uh we were able to Yes it it
took a bit but we
were other
questions a representative Stringham um
just this this program is uh to the best
of everybody's knowledge is still
actively being funded and if we Ur
expenses uh under under 7209 um the 100%
federal funds is is still ongoing still
ongoing actively
funded that that I don't see any other
questions uh rep commissioner do you do
you have any final thoughts for us on
this subject it's really it's really I
almost apologize it's been such a a
contentious hot issue but um but that's
where we're at do you have anything for
us I don't thank you okay and Mr Hampton
you've done a marvelous job so so thank
you for um sitting in there and taking
it thank you representative all right um
so with that I think that concludes uh
our expected presentations do you want
to wrap us up somehow Mr White
uh sure um so I appreciate everyone's uh
attention and questions today on the on
the overall operating budget I think Ju
Just in summary one one important thing
that I kind of think about is much of
what you've seen today are the are the
people and the systems that support the
overarching operations it's it's it ends
up being about I think back the envelope
math about 7% of our total budget um
that that supports everything else so um
you know that that's where we kind of
wanted to start to give you a sense of
of what are the underlying um functions
that support all of the subsequent
divisions that we're going to be
discussing um Henry Litman will be here
on Friday um discussing Medicaid all day
long and uh looking forward to it if
there's any questions or any specific
issues that we that weren't discussed
yesterday or today um that you're
looking for questions in advance of that
please let us know we'll be preparing
for that in the intermediary I I I I I
have a couple clues in that regard yes
um I I don't know what who created the
sheet but there's a sheet that's been
floating around that's got five proposed
significant changes to Medicaid that are
reflected in the governor's budget you
know one of them is I I don't even know
I don't even remember what the five are
but I think those are probably
historically in the last 6 months the
the five of the many that Mr Litman
worked on for which there was a a
Medicaid impact statement done and
considered by the governor's office I'd
be curious in the other topics that were
looked at for changes to Medicaid that
were not accepted by the governor's
office what what do you think about that
um so the governor's office is working
on finalizing the hb2 provisions so that
it's clear uh to the committee what the
changes are relative to premiums
eligibility in cost sharing and so we
will be going into details on that and
then we are um working on getting that
information uh that that has been
requested okay so then the other part of
the request are the ones that didn't get
accepted by the governor that we may
still need to consider yeah I I I think
we can certainly talk about that um part
of part of what uh you will see on
Friday is we were primarily looking at
um or the governor's offices primarily
included the eligibility as as far as
coming into the system and not taking
away current benefits that exist today
um I think that's uh sort of a it's a
very different conversation one's
reducing what's received today one is uh
basically um restricting sort of your
inputs into the system um and and we'll
be prepared to talk about both those
super and then I I just thought of one
of the questions I meant for Mr weers
and and it um uh
there is a two capital budget items one
of them for about $33 million and the
other one for about3 million of which
most of it's Federal but but I'm curious
uh do those Capital budgets
contain money for the Consultants that
would be necessary to implement it if
the capital budget is approved or am I
having to worry about consultancy in the
hb1 to support potential Capital budgets
yep so the um the first item the 33
million and change uh for the the mmes
our modularization project um it's
important to understand a that that's a
9010 match so we're getting 90% federal
funds for every 10 every 10% of General
funds and we would be paying uh for
those Consultants out of that capital
budget so we would not expect to have a
discussion or see anything in the
operating budget on that specific topic
here that's answer my question thank you
of course and representative Stringham
you got it I'm oh representative tki I
had one um I am a little disappointed
that we're doing Medicaid on Friday when
we haven't seen the Medicaid changes
that are being proposed by the governor
and I'm afraid that we booked a big
block of time which is great but we're
not going to have the materials needed
are we going to be able to have drafts
before us I spoke with um Michael Kane
today and he did not anticipate that we
would have what we needed by Friday I'll
jump in on that grenade uh I I have a
hard copy of the five in my office and I
would be happy to go get it so it can be
photocopied I guess I would like an is
it official I'd like an official
distribution of some sort it concerns me
that we haven't had a chance to review
things it's not official because uh Mr
White just said it's got to go into hb2
before it's official I I can give you
what they're working on the five if
you'd like or not I would like to see it
I guess I'm just concerned that we're
going to have a deep dive into Medicaid
and we have a whole chunk of hb2 that we
don't have a draft of I I I think what
we will be able to do is we will be able
to speak to the specifics um it's just
uh the the tricky situation that we're
in of course is that we don't yet have
the specific hb2 Provisions finalized
however um I I would anticipate that
they will be fairly straightforward as
far as um you know we we will be able to
say you know
x% of this particular uh standard
Medicaid population will now have cost
sharing or a premium or whatever it
might be so we will be able to get into
those details we just won't have the
final hb2 to work from but but I don't
think it will be wasted time by any
means if it's possible that we could get
as much Advanced um documentation on
that I think that it's better than us
coming in cold on Friday make us better
prepared to handle the conversation of
course thank you and if not adequate
because it's such a huge part of the
budget if if you don't believe it's
adequate we'll we'll schedule a second I
think we're going to have to anyway
because it's a huge part of the budget
so that's great thank you all right uh
Mr Ripple would would you would you
please start thinking about our calendar
and where we might add sort of a second
scoop of the ice cream for some of these
things like Medicaid sure I will so as
the calendar stands now March 11th is
the last presentation date so you'll
still have a little bit in excess of two
weeks before the division after that
before the division will need to make
its recommendations so there will be
time for a second go around to some of
these so say again the drop dead date
for division three to know what we want
to say to the full finance committee um
I believe we had been using March 27th
as the drop dead date but I do just want
to confirm that and that that's
consistent with what the other divisions
are doing too all
right and anything else representative
tki represent Stringham representative
Stringham just in terms of the numbers
that were provided for us for for the
Medicaid you know we obviously saw some
pretty uh strong uh significant
reductions does that incorporate
everything that's being worked on or
those numbers change with these uh
revisions to hb2 those numbers reflect
the policy changes
okay anything
else not seeing anything from the
members do you have anything the final
words for us Mr White I do not thank you
for your time Dr hen you're the you're
the senior you got anything all right
then Mr Ripple what what what do we
looking at we got something going on
Friday afternoon yep Friday afternoon
Medicaid at 1:00 it wasn't in the last
calendar but it'll be in the calendar
that comes out tomorrow and and what's
our status on when we're going to hear
the non- gerain amendment to
hp71 so I've asked Janet to schedule
that for the next time there's a full
finance committee hearing but at this
point I don't think there are any bills
that have come out of the divisions yet
um for that meeting to be held how how
about the amendment do do we I'm so
sorry I'm confused by this are we do we
need to have a a specific hearing on the
amendment that we heard for 519 that we
are now wanting to attach or thinking we
want to attach to 71 is that its own yes
yes you will and I my understanding was
that would be scheduled for the next
full finance committee meeting but
there's no other business to come before
full Finance as of yet so I think it's
going to be scheduled in combination
with some other things okay that's
that's more clear do you have anything
to
add
okay all right then with that uh we are
adjourned thank you very
much e